MonkaW
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Oh, gerade aufgestanden vor, keine Ahnung, 5, 6 Minuten.
Oh, ich penne noch halb, ey.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, wir machen jetzt einfach Stream an.
Weil es ist ja auch Waren im Stream, da kann ich auch selbst mal aufwachen, sonst bin ich ja schon immer wach.
Monkeys.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
heute ist passives Einkommen angesagt.
Wir hatten gestern
massive, big Wartungsarbeiten
auf der Arbeit.
Und jetzt haben wir alle
Rufbereitschaft bis Montag.
Und es wird sehr, sehr
wahrscheinlich nichts sein.
Aber es wird bezahlt.
Huge passives Einkommen.
Du wirst nichts machen.
Einzige, was ich hab, ist, ich hab das Handy von der Arbeit hier neben liegen.
Ansonsten werde ich quasi gerade bezahlt, indirekt fürs Streamen, wenn man so will.
Oh, ich war noch gar nicht auf dem Klo.
Kann sein, dass ich gleich mal
notgedrungen hier
afgen muss.
Aber jetzt,
jetzt gerade nicht.
Oh, ich habe schon wieder mal Pille, meine Pille
vergessen. Sekunde, muss ich gerade mal reinhauen.
Ja, werde ich auch.
werde ich auch.
Ich werde quasi heute
für alles, was ich mache, bezahlt.
Egal, was es ist.
Ich kriege passiv Geld.
Exzellent, oder?
Aber
Ganz umsonst ist es nicht.
Weil
ist dann auch alles ein Arbeitsunfall.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber so ganz umsonst
ist es ja nicht.
Ich meine, ich muss immerhin
das Handy am Start haben.
hier jetzt 24 7 eigentlich 24 24 1 und innerhalb
ich glaube innerhalb von einer stunde oder so eingeloggt am rechner sein und
was machen können aber wie gesagt die chance dass was passiert ist äußerst gering
Und ich verwende jetzt seit ungefähr 2-3 Wochen meine neue Linux-VM mit Grafikkarte
auf der Arbeit.
Ich muss euch sagen Leute, das ist echt angenehm.
Endlich kein Windows Desktop mehr.
Ich logge mich jetzt ein.
Remote per VPN.
Und dann gehe ich mit RDP auf eine Linux-VM mit XFCE Desktop.
Und im Endeffekt habe ich da alles so eingerichtet wie es sein muss.
Ich habe ein bisschen meine alte VM-Config recycelt, weil das ist ja noch X.
Wayland und RDP funktionieren nicht richtig.
so und mit mit xfc also xorg xfc und meine alten config dafür für profi und und clipboard manager
und alles ist das super angenehm aller ich bin ich kann jetzt endlich mal gescheit arbeiten
ohne dass ich mich permanent mit irgendeinem Windows-Kack rumschlagen muss.
Das geht viel besser und viel angenehmer.
Du kannst halt auch, wenn du unter Linux unterwegs bist,
du kannst halt auch viel mehr verskripten und automatisieren,
als dummes Windows rumgeklicke.
Das ist viel, viel angenehmer.
So.
Monkeis.
Schmeißen wir erstmal hier unseren Linux-Mini-PC an.
Machen Deskflow an.
Pullscreen.
Zack.
Tü-düm, tü-düm.
Ja, und ich hab das jetzt wirklich nice eingerichtet.
Ich hab, wie gesagt,
ich hab meine alte
VM-Core, also das ist im Prinzip das, was auf GitHub ist,
Habe ich recycelt.
Wobei, eine Sache habe ich nicht am Start.
Ich habe Terminator laufen, anstatt Westterm.
Hatte ich aber auf der Arbeit die ganze Zeit schon.
Das liegt daran, weil Westterm braucht OpenGL und GPU-Beschleunigung.
Und da fandst du irgendwie nicht über RDP gescheit.
Keine Ahnung, frag mich nicht.
Deswegen ist Westterm ein Ticken langsamer
Ein Ticken langsamer
Als Terminator
Und gerade wenn man den ganzen Tag
Quasi im Terminal tippt
Ist halt Terminal-Lag wirklich abfuck
Das will man nicht haben
Hast den doofen Emulator
Ach wegen deinem
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, du bist ja mit dem Gameboy-Emulator, gell?
Das ist Hauptsache Wobbly Windows.
Leute, ich habe auf der Arbeit kein Wobbly Windows.
Stellt euch mal vor, das kann XFCE nicht.
Guck mal hier.
Wobbel, wobbel.
Ja, hier, wobbel, wobbel.
Und XFCE kann das nicht.
Wie, guck mal, XFCE, Wobbly, kann, kann.
Also mit Compits früher.
Mit Compits früher ging das.
Aber Compits gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Guck, Kompitz.
Ja.
Mit Kompitz, das wusste ich, dass das mit Kompitz geht.
Aber ich glaube, es gibt...
Kompitz gibt es doch gar nicht mehr unter aktuellem Ubuntu, oder?
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Ubuntu Latest, gibt es da noch Kompitz?
Nee, oder im Leben nicht.
Äh.
Updaten?
Ne, da gibt es kein Compits. Compits ist dead, oder?
GitHub? Compits?
Aber das braucht halt auch OpenGL.
Keine Ahnung, wie gut das funzt mit...
Mit 20 years ago.
Ja, keine Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert.
Per...
Was ist Bashly?
Absearch Compits.
Guck mal mal.
Oh!
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Es gibt Compits noch unter Ubuntu?
Wirklich?
Alter!
Damit hätte ich jetzt wirklich nicht gerechnet.
Moment, das ist ein anderes Compitz als das Compitz von früher.
Weil das hier ist das Compitz, was man braucht, ist Compitz 08.
Und das ist Compitz, das ist Compitz 914.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Naja, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
Wobbly Windows über RDP ist eh dumm,
weil RDP ruckeln die Windows,
wenn du sie verschiebst so ein bisschen.
Da hat man das nicht.
Da kann man das nicht so schön smooth wobbeln lassen.
Ich glaube, ich werde auf der Arbeit auf Wobbly Windows verzichten.
Wie es der Katze geht?
Also, ich habe keine Katze aktuell.
Ich habe eine, die mich öfters mal besucht.
Die war heute Morgen schon da
und hat wieder was zu fressen abgegriffen.
und die ist mittlerweile pünktlich, Leute,
ohne Scheiß, 7.30 Uhr,
steht die vor der Tür
und wenn ich das Fenster im Bad aufmache,
sprintet sie vors Fenster,
Mau, Mau, Mau,
ja, ja, Katze, ich mach gleich die Tür auf
und sobald die Tür auf war, rein in die Küche gerannt,
wird wild angefangen zu brummen
und sich hingelegt,
muss ein bisschen streicheln und dann gleich
Futter, also eine Minute streicheln,
ich glaube, die lässt sich ja streicheln, um gut Wetter
zu machen für mich, ja, so nach dem Motto,
Die muss mich quasi noch weichklopfen, dass ich was zu futtern rausrücke.
Und dann futter und dann zack.
Wird das reingefuttert bis wirklich auf den allerletzten Krümel.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, wie das macht.
Die ist wirklich pünktlich.
Manchmal sitzt die auch schon eine halbe Stunde zu früh da.
Afrika, Amerika, Europe.
Amsterdam ist mir doch scheißegal.
Das ist für uns wirklich?
Man kann Compets installieren?
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Krass.
Aber das können wir abbrechen, weil im Docker wird das mit OpenGL höchstwahrscheinlich
je nachdem funktionieren.
Wobei, wenn man das passende Device weiterleitet, vielleicht doch.
Also die Katze, die ist so dick.
Sehr wohl genährt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Hunger gelitten hat, bevor ich sie gefüttert habe.
So, wir müssen jetzt natürlich erstmal noch das System-Update machen.
Yes.
Was haben wir hier alles?
4 GB einfach wieder.
Was für ein Size hier.
4,5 GB Update.
Message.
Big Jungle Update.
So, und dann machen wir noch gleich die
Our-Packages, in der Hoffnung, wir werden nicht gleich
wieder Supply Chain Attacked.
Monka W.
Leute, das ist...
Also wie gesagt, ich habe es ja gerade erzählt, ich arbeite jetzt komplett über eine Linux-VM auf der Arbeit.
Die einzigen Sachen, ich überlege gerade, für was brauche ich noch Windows?
Ja, für Teams brauche ich Windows.
Also Teams läuft ohne Probleme als PWA unter Linux.
Echt erstaunlich gut, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus? Benutzt ihr Teams unter Linux?
Also ich muss sagen, die PWA, also ich habe in Chrome die Teams-PWA laufen,
die funzt inklusive Screensharing und allem.
Überhaupt kein Problem. Funzt einfach.
Was nicht funktioniert ist Audio-Video über meine Linux-VM.
Weil ich noch nicht gecheckt habe, wie ich über RDP Sound und Mikrofon rüberkriege.
Das habe ich noch nicht so ganz kapiert.
Aber gut. Kannst nichts machen.
So, zumindest mega nice.
Funzt alles.
Also da kann man sich echt nicht beschweren.
Ja, und zumindest ist es da so.
Also die
VM.
Was wollte ich euch denn gerade
erzählen?
RDP?
Ich wollte aber...
Achso, genau. Was da ganz witzig ist,
ich muss da ein bisschen tricksen.
Du hast von dort
nicht
direkt einen Internetzugriff.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja immerhin,
auch wenn es eine Admin
vms ist ja immer noch hier business enterprise environment du hast nicht direkt internet internet
zugang du musst du ein proxy du musst du ein proxy rausgehen und in den proxy sind halt manche sachen
nicht freigeschaltet und das habe ich gemerkt die proxy regeln sind relativ uneinheitlich ja die die
sind beispielsweise wenn ich von der vm die müssen das irgendwie ip range freigeschaltet haben oder
Also wenn ich von meiner Linux-VM ins Internet gehe, sind zum Beispiel, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, macht aus meiner Sicht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
Visual Studio Code Extensions, der Visual Studio Code App Store ist gesperrt.
Obwohl man die VM mit einem installierten Visual Studio Code und Extensions starten kann.
Also, wenn der bei dem Boot und bei dem initialen Provisioning
Lädt er dann quasi bei jedem Neustart die Plugins runter
Und packt sie einem da rein
Aber selbst installieren kann man sie im laufenden Betrieb nicht
Also total weird
Ich denke mal, die haben das einfach nicht ausprobiert
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen
Aber von meiner Zytrix Windows VM
Da geht natürlich
Weil es ja auch unter Windows so viel sicherer ist
irgendwelche Random Plugins zu installieren
unter Linux, da geht der
Visual Studio Code Store
und wisst ihr
was ich jetzt gemacht habe? Trick 17
ich hab mir einen SSH Tunnel
gemacht mit Socks Proxy
und leite einfach alles
was
auf der Zytrix VM geht und auf der
Linux VM nicht, über einen SSH
Socks Proxy an die Zytrix VM
und ich weiß
Hey, prinzipiell ist es ja erlaubt, sonst würde das nicht von Windows ausgehen, Alter.
Das Funs.
Das funktioniert deutlich einfacher, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Hier, Our Packages.
Jet Brains Toolbox.
Okay, bam.
Jet Brains Toolbox updaten.
Soll ich euch mal zeigen, wie einfach es ist, einen Reverse-Socks-Proxy mit SSH zu machen?
Und bevor ich euch das zeige, die Frage, hat jemand überhaupt eine Ahnung, von was ich rede?
Beziehungsweise gibt es jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, wovon ich rede?
Beziehungsweise, wo ich nochmal erklären soll, was mit einem Reverse-Socks-Proxy gemeint ist?
Also wir machen jetzt erstmal
Toolbox Updates
Hier Update, Update, Update
Jawohl, check for updates
SSH-L? Nein, nein, nein
Nicht SSH-L
Eine Kombination aus SSH-D
Und SSH-R
Also ich versuche euch das mal zu erklären
während ihr updatet. Ich weiß nicht,
wie schnell mein Rechner ist, weil er ist ziemlich ausgelastet
gerade, okay? Also, stellt
euch vor, wie machen wir das am besten?
Okay, stellt euch vor,
ihr lockt euch
also, auf dem Rechner hier,
okay? Auf dem hier. Wir machen
das mal so. Also, auf dem Rechner, wo
dieser Prompt hier ist, ja? Da habt
ihr Internetzugang und könnt alle möglichen Seiten
aufmachen. Z schon ausprobiert? Ne.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht, warum genau. Machen wir das mal
Kieselweich, mach mir das mal schmackhaft, warum ich das ausprobieren sollte.
Warum das besser ist, als einfach Whistle Studio Code und Jetbrains IDE ist.
Wenn man jetzt keinen Bock hat, zwei Monate zu customizen.
Außer, dass er...
Okay, er ist written in Rust.
Blazingly fast laser speed.
Aber ansonsten...
Keine Ahnung.
IDK.
Also, stellt euch vor hier.
So, auf dem Rechner hier, den ihr hier seht, da habt ihr Zugriff aufs Internet.
Gar kein Problem.
Na, hier curl.google.de.
So, bam.
Funzt.
Ist moved, aber ist kein Problem.
Wir können mal curl-l machen und dann sieht man Google gedöhnt.
Okay?
Alles klar?
Also von hier funzt das Internet.
So, und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt einen anderen Rechner.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal, nehmen wir mal einen Raspberry Pi.
Okay?
Nehmen wir mal meinen Raspberry Pi.
Pi-Ad, war ich hier noch nie drauf.
2.51.
Doch, war ich doch schon.
Oh.
Äh.
Ist es 5,1 oder ist es 5,5?
2,5?
5,5?
Okay.
Also, Chat.
Stellt euch mal vor,
der Rechner hier oben,
der hat keinen Internetzugang, okay?
Der Rechner hier unten hat Internetzugang.
So, ich komme von dem Rechner hier unten
auf den Rechner hier oben per SSH drauf.
So, jetzt könnte man ja sagen,
warum kann ich nicht
einen SSH-Tunnel machen,
von hier nach hier
hier einen
SOX-Proxy aufmachen
und alles, was in den SOX-Proxy reingeht,
kommt hier raus
und geht ins Internet.
Früher war das in der Tat
deutlich komplizierter.
So, hier mal suchen.
SOX-Reverse-SSH
Ja, früher war das ein ziemlicher Tunnel-Org hier.
Ja, früher musstest du hier...
Ne, das ist Blödsinn.
This is Pursuit.
Reverse, SSR, Reverse, Socks, Proxy.
Guck mal, da gibt es auch bestimmt hier...
So, hier, guck mal.
Also früher war das echt ein bisschen komplizierter.
Da musste man so Dinge machen.
Guck.
Man musste lokal, hier auf dem Rechner da unten,
musste man ein SOX-Proxy starten auf Port 54321.
Dann musste man ein SSH-Reverse-Tunnel machen.
Das ist der Port, der auf dem Remote-Rechner aufgeht.
Der wird über SSH weitergeleitet an den lokalen SOX-Proxy.
Das heißt, du hast zwei SSH-Kommandos gebraucht.
Ja.
Und mittlerweile geht das in einem SSH-Kommando
Guck, ich kann es euch zeigen
Mittlerweile kann man einfach machen
SSH-R
Ähm, ja, 80
Ähm
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr sicher
Wie die Sonntags ist
Einfach nur so, 1080
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, fuck
Äh
So, ich glaube so
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich glaube so ist die Sonntags
Ne, ähm
Einf... Einf...
War es einfach nur so?
Empty Reply vom Server.
Okay. So, und jetzt kann man sagen,
Curl mit Socks Proxy.
Ähm.
Hier.
Local Host.
localhost port 8080
example.com
und ihr seht curl geht jetzt
ich kann euch das auch beweisen ich glaube curl schreibt das hier
so hin
ja guck curl geht jetzt
über den
socks proxy wie ihr hier seht
ja connect
über den socks proxy
localhost port 1080 dahin das heißt ihr könnt quasi wenn ihr eine kiste hat mit ssh drauf wo
ihr euch auf der andere kiste verbinden kann die nicht ins internet kommen oder die nicht
überall im Internet hinkommt,
könnt ihr euch so easy tunneln.
Einfach so. Einfach so.
Das ist alles.
Umgedreht geht auch. Umgedreht
ist ssh-d.
ssh-d
macht das Ganze umgedreht.
Das heißt, hier wird ein Port aufgemacht
und alles, was über den Tunnel geht, kommt da oben raus.
Also ich sehe hier
kein Problem mit Security-Abteilung, weil
letztendlich.
Ich tunnel ja nur von
also von offizieller
Kiste auf offizielle Kiste
auf Sachen, die eh erlaubt
sind auf der anderen Kiste.
Also, wenig juckt's.
Wenn du das natürlich machst,
um dich von Servern rauszutunneln, die nicht
ins Internet sollen, dann würde ich
das nicht unbedingt machen.
So.
So sieht's aus.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet? Das geupdatet?
Jawohl. Das ist auch alles geupdatet.
Dann machen wir mal
Pack Cache. Wie war das?
Pack Cache
minus KR0?
Ne. Oh, katz.
Backcash clear
Hast du das hier schon gesehen?
Einmal zum KekW
Moment
Muss ich mal vorschau gucken
Nicht, dass ihr mir irgendwelche anstößigen Videos schickt
Und jetzt gleich gebannt werde
Neue Hoffnung für deutsche Wirtschaft
Lidl gegen Amazon
So will Deutschland digital unabhängiger werden
Okay, okay, das können wir uns tatsächlich
Das ist ein gutes Video für den Stream
Das können wir uns tatsächlich angucken
Ich fürchte aber, dass es halt mal wieder typisches, wobei, okay, man muss den zugute halten, hey, man muss den echt zugute halten.
Das ist kein Regierungs- oder Europaprojekt.
Das heißt, das ist nicht von Anfang an zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Da sitzt ordentlich Geld dahinter und Lidl hat ja auch schon ganz gut was auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Lidl hatte aber schlicht und ergreifend einfach noch nicht genug Zeit.
Das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen.
Guck mal, wie lange gibt es AWS? AWS war ja somit das erste. Wie lange gibt es AWS schon? 2018 oder? Ach, fuck, Alter. 2018, das muss viel länger sein. Guck mal. Guck mal hier. 2006. Die hatten 20 Jahre Zeit, ihren Service auszubauen. Da kann Lidl nicht in 5, 6 Jahren das komplett aufholen.
Aber das können wir uns trotzdem gleich angucken
Lass mich nur mal kurz gucken, wie man Pack
Packcache, ich war doch gar nicht so verkehrt
Wir wollen 0 Packages behalten
Hier, zack
Packcache
Zack
Alter
Wie viele Gigabytes hatte ich da
Bitteschön in meinem Cache
62 Gig
Was habe ich denn da alles gecached
das halbe Internet, oder was?
Omega-Lul.
Gab's nicht
NC-DU auch mit Color in letzter Zeit?
Ja, hier doch. NC-DU mit Color.
Lass mal kurz
checken, wie groß mein Home
jetzt ist mittlerweile.
Boah, ist immer noch ordentlich.
Aber ich meine, ich hab ne 500 GB SSD
drinne. Das sollte reichen.
Okay, Local. Das ist auf jeden Fall JetBrains.
Repos, Linux-Kernel
ein paar Mal ausgecheckt. Gut, der braucht natürlich
auch ordentlich Speicher.
Cache, JetBrains, was sonst?
Und ein paar Downloads.
Okay, das können wir tatsächlich
löschen. Das können wir auch löschen.
Äh, weiß ich gar nicht
mehr, was das ist. Das können wir auch löschen.
Kekkel haben wir hier.
Ich weiß nicht, wofür wir das ausgecheckt haben.
Ach, Terminal-Browser. Packet Tracer,
den lassen wir tatsächlich da.
Hier.
So und jetzt Chat
Was kommt jetzt
Reboot
Zack
Haben wir geupdatet
War bestimmt ein Körnel dabei
Bei 4,5 Gig Security Updates
Ja Kanisterkoppel das kannst du machen
Solange du erst das H-Axis hast
Was ist an der GitHub-Seite vom Kernel so schlecht?
Die sieht halt, naja gut, okay, doch, du hast recht, die ist schlecht.
Die sieht halt aus wie von 1992, die GitHub-Seite vom Linux-Kernel.
Das stimmt schon.
Ups, oh, falscher Knopf
Falscher Knopf, es war noch nicht ready
Es war noch nicht ready, jetzt ist es ready
Firefox, schade
Es müsste doch irgendwo bei KDE auch so ein
Session Manager geben, der mit dem ganzen Kram
Immer wieder startet, wenn ich hier reingehe
So, ähm
Hier, GitHub, Linux
Die Kernel-Seite sieht halt aus
Wie 1992, ja, hier unten
Aber das Ding sieht halt schon immer so aus.
Ist halt komplett, komplett Plain Text.
Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendein spezielles Markdown-Format sein soll.
Bei mir rendert das zumindest hier nicht.
Chatterino.
So.
ja das neueste issue wieso ist es von es gibt gar keine issues im im projekt das
ist jetzt aber auch nichts neues oder
oder was meinst du
mich würde deine sicht auf die entwicklung von einklössigen formen die
die Entwicklung zu verlangsamen, interessieren.
Naja, das ist Blödsinn. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Also du kannst davon ausgehen,
wir können uns hier in Deutschland
oder in der EU kaputt regulieren.
Der Welt wird es egal sein.
Also in der Regel
kann man eigentlich davon ausgehen,
was möglich ist und was
Geld verspricht, wird gemacht.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar
Dinger, da konnte man
sich weltweit drauf einigen.
dass das keine allzu gute Idee ist, zum Beispiel Menschen zu klonen oder sowas, ja, da hat man sich ja so quasi indirekt auf der Welt, weltweit verständigt, dass man das vielleicht besser lässt, aber insgesamt wird das gemacht, was möglich ist und was Geld bringt und das wird beim Thema AI-Entwicklung auch passieren.
Und wenn wir das, also wenn wir, ich meine wir sind jetzt ja schon hinten dran, as fuck, ja
Und gut, dass wir mittlerweile eine Regelung haben, dass, also gut in Anführungsstrichen, ja
Eine Regelung haben, dass alle mögliche KI-Sache gekennzeichnet werden muss
Also wir haben uns schon wieder kaputt reguliert, bevor wir überhaupt aufgeholt haben
Deswegen sehe ich das auch nicht
Also die Entwicklung von KI zu verlangsamen wird nicht funktionieren
Es sei denn, wir werden an eine technische Grenze stoßen
Also es sei denn, wir stoßen an die
Technischen Grenzen von LLMs
Das kann ja auch sein, man weiß es ja nicht
Aktuell ist das Ganze ja noch relativ
Unoptimiert, du musst bei jedem Request
Was du an so ein LLM stellst
Musst du den gesamten Kontext
Da
Parat haben
Und das geht ja auch noch bis zum gewissen Limit
Das hat ja keine
richtiges Gedächtnis in dem Sinn.
Und was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst
alte Konversationen zusammenfassen,
dass er die dann wieder, aber da gehen immer Infos
verloren. Also,
an diese Grenzen könnte man natürlich irgendwann geraten,
dass man sagt, okay, das
wird einfach nicht mehr nennenswert
besser. Du musst immer mehr Hardware, immer
mehr Strom, immer mehr Geld da reinschicken,
für marginale
Verbesserung. Das könnte ja durchaus sein,
dass man so ein Plateau erreicht
und dass es dann langsamer wird. Aber
Aber das wird bestimmt nicht langsam, weil irgendjemand sagt, wir wollen es langsamer machen.
Schon gar nicht, wenn wir das in Deutschland oder in der EU sagen.
Da denken sich die Amis und die Chinesen, ich keck W mir mal ein und machen das trotzdem.
Also alles, was da geht, was Geld verspricht, das wird gemacht.
Also das kann ich mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir in nächster Zeit in Deutschland und Europa einen großartigen Einfluss auf Cutting Edge KI-Entwicklung haben werden.
Beziehungsweise vorne mit dabei sein. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
wir sind schon dabei, Sachen zu regulieren
die quasi
wenn einer nur dran denkt
wird das bei uns ja schon reguliert
also keine Ahnung, was da abgeht
ich glaube nicht, dass wir da demnächst
vorne mit dabei vorgehen
und ansonsten, allgemein
ich hab mich ja schon öfters zu dem Thema ausgelassen
allgemein muss man sagen
das was der Nvidia-Chef erzählt hat
der ist schon in Funkenwahrheit dran
der hat ja letztens so eine Präsentation gehalten
wo er irgendwie 20 mal erzählt hat tokens gleich profit tokens gleich profit ich weiß nicht ob er profit gesagt hat oder money
in den profit hat er glaube ich gesagt tokens gleich profit tokens gleich profit ja gut für ihn ich meine er ist der chef von Nvidia
die verdienen nach jedem token geld aber das meine ich gar nicht er hat ja auch gesagt so sinngemäß ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
ob das die richtigen zahlen waren der hat ja sinngemäß auch in dem vortrag gesagt wenn du einen engineer einstellst für 150.000 euro im jahr
und der nicht mindestens 150.000 Euro an Tokens nochmal verbraucht im Jahr, dann ist er nicht effektiv.
Da ist schon ein Funken Wahrheit dran.
Also sei es jetzt, ich meine ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler, ich programmiere aber auch ganz gerne.
Und gerade zur Unterstützung, also ich sehe es noch nicht in nächster Zeit,
dass man ein sinnvolles Softwareprojekt starten kann, das komplett vibecoded ist von jemand, der es nicht versteht auf technischer Ebene.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, da sind wir noch ganz weit von entfernt.
Das funktioniert ganz gut, wenn sich Manager XY hinsetzt und sagt, Alter, ich brauche eine Webseite da und dafür.
Okay, das ist dann so Proof of Concept, erster Aufschlag, Webseite mit ein bisschen 0815 CSS.
Das funktioniert dann schon ganz gut, ja.
Aber größere, komplexere Anwendungen von jemand, der nicht versteht, was da passiert,
da sind wir, glaube ich, noch eine ganze Weile entfernt.
Also wir reden jetzt nicht von einmalig irgendwas ausscheißen, was zu 90% funktioniert,
sondern wir reden von jahrelanger Entwicklung und Weiterentwicklung.
Und das nur vibe-coded only von jemand, der von der Technik keine Ahnung hat,
das sehe ich beim besten Willen nicht.
Das sehe ich auch die nächsten Jahre noch nicht.
aber der Nvidia Chef hat schon
einen gewissen Punkt
bei der ganzen Sache, du bist
deutlich effektiver, sei es jetzt als
Softwareentwickler, sei es jetzt als
Admin, als DevOps Engineer, als
Site Reliability, was auch immer, wenn du irgendwas
IT mäßig, wenn du was mit Computer
wie meine Oma früher gesagt hat, machst
dann bist du einfach deutlich effektiver
ich merke das auch tagtäglich
wofür ich das beispielsweise
ich hab das erst gestern
wieder verwendet, ja
Mich hat es gestern übelst abgefuckt, wie kompliziert das ist per AWX.
Ich weiß nicht, kennt ihr AWX?
Ich habe AWX.
Chatgewehr kennt AWX von euch?
Das da?
Ja, da gibt es ein...
Das ist...
Ich zeige euch mal ein Bild.
Das ist ein Webinterface für Ansible im Endeffekt, ja.
So sieht es aus.
Da kannst du quasi Ansible, Playbooks und so drüber starten.
Das ist quasi eine Automation-Plattform, nennt sich das mittlerweile, AAP.
Ja, da kannst du zum Beispiel sagen, okay, hier ist doch beispielsweise ein ganz gutes Beispiel.
Du hast ein Job-Template, wo jemand die Logik dahinter schon implementiert hat
und du füllst jetzt nur noch Parameter aus und dann läuft das gegen bestimmte Server.
Mittlerweile heißt das Automation-Plattform.
So, und da gibt es ein offizielles Command-Line-Tool dafür, um das anzusprechen, weil man hatte nicht immer Bock im Webinterface rumzuklicken. Das offizielle Command-Line-Tool ist hier unter AWX-Kit. Das Problem ist nur, dass Red Hat mal wieder Upfuck Red Hat ist und die letzte Version von AWX, beziehungsweise auch AWX-Kit, wurde 24.6. äh, wurde, nicht 24.6. Alter, wurde, ähm, Moment.
Januar, Februar, März, April
Mai
Juni, Juli
Ne, okay, das ist nicht, das ist nicht der Monat
Ich hab irgendwie schon gedacht, aber es passt nicht
Zumindest
Die wurde 2024
Wurde das Ding released, ja
Und im Prinzip hat RedHead
Bisher die ganzen Sachen nur
Verschlimmbessert hier, ja, die haben
Authentifizierungsmaßnahmen, also RedHead hat wirklich
Richtig reingeschissen und das Ding ist auch
In der Version, was sie released haben, total
verbuggt.
Also, was habe ich gemacht?
Ich bin in das Repo gegangen, habe mir den
Master ausgecheckt, äh, Devil,
nicht Devil, nicht Master, Devil Branch,
habe ein paar
Comets zurückgerollt, wo ein paar Sachen
gefixt wurden, habe mir das selbst gebaut.
So, und dann ist das Ding aber immer noch super
eklig zu bedienen, das AWX
Command Line Tool, und dann bin ich einfach
hergegangen und habe gesagt, ey,
Opus 5,
ich habe ein bisschen was von Hand zusammen
gekryptet, ja, also AWX
ad hoc commands
create, blablabla, limit
so, wie man quasi commands starten
kann über AX, habe ich hier zusammen
zusammen gewurschtelt
und dann habe ich am Ende das
dann habe ich an manchen Stellen drunter
drunter geschrieben, so hier
please insert
command prompt
here via vim und so gedönst
so, und dann habe ich das
genommen am Ende, nach opus 5
copy pasted
und zack, ich meine, der hat das ein bisschen
zu kompliziert gemacht, okay,
ja, und zack, hat er mir dann
was richtig Nices gebaut,
der hat mir aus einer JSON-Datei
für FZF was gebaut,
wo ich mir den Host raussuchen kann,
das Ganze schön tabellarisch da noch
ausgegeben, da vorne Abfrage, wollen sie das
wirklich ausführen,
dafür ist das super, ich habe danach noch ein bisschen was
drin rumeditiert und
jetzt verwende ich das, jetzt habe ich quasi
so ein Command-Max-Server-Overview
oder irgendwie so sinngemäß heißt das,
dann ploppt bei mir quasi so ein
FZF-Fenster auf.
Ja, so wo ich die Server auswählen
kann. Das kann ich jetzt nicht nachmachen, weil ich hab
hier keine Serverliste. Oder hab ich doch?
Warte mal. SSH-List
Servers. Known Host.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Cat. SSH.
Known Host.
Aha.
Cat-D
F1.
jawohl, FC, so, da habe ich
eine Serverliste, okay
das ist jetzt relativ unsinnig, ja, normaler
also in meiner Serverliste, die generiert
wird aus
aus dem Ansible Inventory
habe ich hier stehen, IP,
Servername, Serverstatus, Serverstand
und Server Service
Server Stage, das glaube ich alles drin
da kann ich dann da drin suchen, ja, zum Beispiel
ich suche jetzt den Server
bla blub in prod
mal sinngemäß hier irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, den Server will ich
dann kann ich das ganze übrigens mit fcp da kann ich sagen okay ich will jetzt diese diese kisten
hier haben so da kann ich die selekten okay man kann die selekten und am ende kriegt man eine
liste raus was man für server haben will und die auf denen wird einmal ein simple command
ausgeführt das ist ein mega praktisch das habe ich gestern gestern programmiert und habe mir
immer zwischendrin snippets aus opus geholt du bist also das hätte ich im leben sonst nicht
nicht innerhalb von einem tag hingekriegt ich habe gestern wegen den wartungsarbeiten ganzen
tag vom rechner gesessen hat bis auf ein paar skripte ausführen nichts machen müssen ja und
das ist halt so ein ding du wirst wahnsinnig viel effektiver das ist wirklich so also da ist was
dran was der nvidia chef gesagt hat dass du wenn du nicht wenn ich meine das ist jetzt natürlich
nvidia ja wenn du 150 km jahr verdienst musste 150 kartons ausgeben ob das jetzt wirklich eins
zu 1 so ist, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich ist das Blödsinn,
aber da ist auf jeden Fall was dran.
Ja, also für Leute, die KI
komplett ignorieren, die
sind viel ineffektiver als Leute, die
KI sinnvoll benutzen.
Und mit sinnvoll benutzen ist bei mir nicht
gemeint, hallo liebes
Chat-GPT,
bitte
installier mir, wobei das ist noch
zu einfach, bitte rolle auf allen
Servern von
Produkt XY dieses
Playbook aus und mach das,
Also ganz ehrlich, da vertraue ich den Agents zu wenig, die PSSH auf meine Server mit Root-Zugriff loszulassen.
Aber zum Ideen holen und so Sachen zu entwickeln, ist das immer wieder Snippets checken zu lassen.
Ja, oder wofür KI auch wunderbar ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt irgendwie eine JSON-Response.
Ja, warte mal.
Example JSON, da gibt es doch super JSON-APIs irgendwo.
chat was ist was was ist beste was ist beste jason example api star wars star wars api gibt
es auch immer star wars api okay so zack was kann man da jetzt was kann man da jetzt können
Okay
Wir curlen das jetzt einfach, ist ja egal
So, stellt euch vor, ihr habt
Ihr habt hier irgendwas gecurlt, so
Nach JQ das Ganze rein
Sondern ihr habt jetzt irgendwie einen total abgedrehten Filter
Gemacht mit JQ
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken
Ich glaube, jetzt kann man hier sagen, irgendwie
Species
Ja, irgendwie so, Leerzeichen
Punkt, Starship
Wir bräuchten jetzt ein bisschen was.
Siehst du, jetzt weiß ich schon wieder nicht,
wie das genau funktioniert.
Ich glaube so, oder?
Nee.
Okay, Leute.
Ich bin schon wieder zu dumm dafür,
überhaupt die Sonntags zu checken.
So, stellt euch vor,
ihr habt jetzt quasi Jason ab,
ihr habt euch irgendwie was mit JQ zusammengebastelt
und jetzt nehmt ihr das da
und sagt der KI, ey,
bauen wir mal da draus
eine ordentliche Darstellung, tabellarisch,
äh, human readable
Darstellung, tabellarisch,
äh, wo ich mit FZF drüber
Fuzzy fighten kann. Und dann baut
euch die KI, so ein, so ein
One-Liner zusammen und
zu 99% funktioniert
das First Try genauso, wie ihr haben wollt, wenn ihr
ein gescheites Model verwendet. Also dafür ist
das mega praktisch und ihr hättet
wahrscheinlich eine halbe Stunde gebraucht, wenn ihr das von
Hand zusammengewurschtelt hättet.
Wie soll ich
das machen? Ich habe keine gescheite API. Okay.
Ähm, außerdem bin ich
KI-technisch nirgendswo an. Wir können mal gucken, ob ChatGPT
das hinkriegt. Ich habe da meine Zweifel. ChatGPT
äh, FreeChatGPT
sagt, ähm, Leute, hat jemand
ein Beispiel ab? Hier, guck mal.
Hier, so.
Also,
du kannst als erstes schon mal sagen,
wofür das irgendwie ganz nice ist.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Starships.
Moment, ich dachte, das ist...
Ja, die API sackt dafür.
Ich hätte gern alles
included in der Response.
Das ist ein bisschen okay.
Wir brauchen... Fangen wir doch mal.
Ich brauche
ein Exempel JSON-API,
die nested Strukturen
hat. Welcher Service
ist da für Looter?
Keine Ahnung, es gibt doch bestimmt irgendeine Jason-RP, wo ein bisschen was nested ist.
Okay, Chat-GPT, so wie wir es haben, schon wieder zu dumm.
Dummi-RP.
Okay, taugt das?
Jason-Placeholder, das ist gut, das kenne ich.
Jason-Placeholder.
Ja.
Aber das ist auch nicht großartig nested.
Naja gut, wir machen das jetzt trotzdem.
Also, machen wir es mal nur exemplarisch.
Wofür die KI richtig gut ist, ja.
Wenn du denen sagst, also keine Ahnung, ob Free Chat GPT da gut genug für ist, ja.
Kannst du jetzt irgendwie sowas sagen wie,
Ich brauche eine menschenlesbare Table-Darstellung, die man auch gut per FZF filtern kann.
So, mal gucken, ob Chat GPT das checkt.
Also Opus, easy. Opus wird dir das sofort.
Ja, genau. Hier, guck. Na, ChatGPT macht schon wieder komische Dinger.
Mal gucken, ob das funzt, was ChatGPT herausgehauen hat. Ja.
Bei ChatGPT ist es irgendwie so, die machen das, also habe ich zumindest den Eindruck, die machen das ein bisschen nach Auslastung.
Manchmal hast du hier auch Thinking gedöhnt, ja.
Aber manchmal auch nicht. Aber das ist, also
FreeChat-GPT ist halt meistens echt für den Arsch.
So, und jetzt kannst du noch
sagen, äh, keine Ahnung.
Ich will ein
Sticky-Header oben, der
sagt, was die einzelnen
Spalten sind. Du kannst, ihr könnt euch da
übrigens auch vertippen oder so, das juckt
das meistens überhaupt gar nicht.
So, und zack. So, guck schon.
Okay, ich hab keinen Sticky-Header.
Ach doch, ich hab einen Sticky-Header. Hier, da.
Guck mal. Funst.
Also ohne Scheiß, dafür
für das Ding hier, ne?
Hättet ihr wahrscheinlich eine Viertelstunde da gesessen,
bis ihr das zusammengewurschtelt habt.
Und ist halt praktisch, ne?
Jetzt könnt ihr hier filtern drinnen.
Zack. Bam. Und ihr kriegt das raus.
Und dann könnt ihr theoretisch dahinter noch,
ja?
Ja, dann könnt ihr dahinter noch
ein AWK machen. Ich benutze das halt so
in Kombination, ne?
Ich lasse mir so Sachen teilweise generieren.
Dann bastle ich noch selbst was dabei.
Guck, jetzt kriege ich nur die IDs dabei.
So.
Sagen wir, okay.
Ich will FZF-Multi-Select haben.
Ich will diese Dinger hier gespeichert haben.
So.
Und jetzt, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wie es geht, kann ich sagen, okay.
Nehme ich das hier mal.
Wenn ihr einen Agent habt, geht das natürlich besser.
Dann müsst ihr es nicht in den Chat kopieren.
Dann könnt ihr direkt darauf zugreifen.
Ich will, dass es keine New Lines hat, sondern Comma Separated Results sind.
So, bam.
Und jetzt Paste SD, genau das, was man braucht.
Japp.
Guck, jetzt selekte ich hier den Kram und zack, Comma Separated Liste.
Jetzt könnte ich die irgendwo als Filter verwenden zum Beispiel.
Ja, also das in Kombination.
Du bist, also ohne Scheiß, für das Ding hättest du locker eine Viertelstunde gebraucht,
bis du dir diesen ganzen Krempel hier zusammengewurschtelt hast.
Und das ist halt in dem Fall dann genau das, was ich haben will.
Also es ist wirklich, du bist einfach
viel effektiver, wenn du
KI benutzt, als ohne.
Sunny,
Frage beantwortet.
Bist du überhaupt noch da?
Erstmal drei Stunden geschwätzt und jetzt
ist er gar nicht mehr da.
Kann man hier irgendwie Users listen oder so?
Geht das irgendwie?
Ne.
Okay, du bist noch da.
Excellent.
Und Frage beantwortet.
Das war jetzt recht ausführlich, aber ich glaube, ich bin nicht alles losgeworden.
Excellent.
Ja, dafür ist das gut.
Die KICOs labern viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Es gibt kaum eine Branche, wo so viel gelabert wird als da.
Falscher Knopf.
Da wird viel gelabert, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Wie oft haben sie erzählt, dass es AGI gibt?
Schon? Schon das fünfte Mal oder so?
Wie oft wurde es das letzte Jahr über erzählt, dass man AGI erreicht hat?
Also AGI ist
Wie heißt das? Artificial General Intelligence
Oder sowas
Also quasi eine KI, die wirklich
Denken kann, sozusagen
Menschenähnlich
Wobei ich jetzt
Wahrscheinlich hauen mich jetzt die ganzen KI-Fans
Dass das nicht die korrekte Definition von AGI ist
so gehen wir auf github ja und vielleicht noch eins zu der sache erwähnt das war jetzt kostenloses
chat gpt chat gpt kostenlos ist in der regel ziemlicher krebs aber selbst dafür ist das mehr
als ausreichend wenn ihr ein gescheites model habt dann kommt dann noch teilweise deutlich
besseres und komplexeres bei komplexeren
Fragen auch raus.
Trends.
Trends
of Shitup.
Wie willst du etwa sagen?
Die ganzen CEOs erzählen uns irgendeinen Mist?
Das kann nicht sein.
Ich glaube, das ist immer alles, was sie
sagen. Und wenn die das
Da muss das so sein.
So, wen haben wir denn hier?
Also, was trendet denn diese Woche auf GitHub?
Lasst uns doch mal gucken.
Wir skippen wie immer KI.
Weil sonst wären wir ja einen halben Tag mit beschäftigt, das uns anzugucken.
AI.
Das wollte ich mal irgendwann ausbringen, habe ich noch nicht.
Ist aber auch ein bisschen KI mit dabei.
Glaube ich.
Äh, AI.
Höchstwahrscheinlich AI.
AI.
Home Assistant!
Pog!
Gab's da ein neues Release oder warum trennten da so viele?
Ah, es gab ein neues Release.
Exzellent.
Ich müsste mein Home Assistant auch mal wieder updaten.
Wobei das jetzt nicht so wild ist.
Ich habe meinen Home Assistant natürlich nicht am Internet hängen.
Letztens erst wieder einen Reddit-Post gesehen.
Hilfe, mein Proxmox-Server wurde gehackermanned.
Und das erste, was du liest, ist Proxmox-Login-Page im Internet erreichbar.
Da kannst du dir auch nur denken, Alter.
Kek W.
Warum macht man sowas? Ich weiß es nicht.
Was? Bashly
Bashly GitHub, okay
Bash Command Line Framework and CLI Generator
Das ist drei Jahre alt, schau mal
Was? Create Feature Rich Bash
Jamel?
Nee, oder? Wir haben doch schon genug
Jammel überall.
Na.
Na, ich weiß
nicht.
Ich weiß
nicht, Leute.
Will ich ein Bash-Skript über
einen Jammel-File generieren?
Okay, das mit dem Argumenten-Parser und so,
das ist ganz nice.
Na
Ne Chat ich glaube das will ich nicht
Ich will kein YAML
Config File
Brauchen um mein Bash Script zu generieren
Also
Bauchgefühl sagt mir
Irgendwie finde ich es nicht so geil
Mein Home Assistant kann ins Internet
aber das Internet kann nicht auf mein Home Assistant.
Warum fragst du?
Willst du meinen Home Assistant
hackermannen?
Humanizer.
AI?
Kein AI, tatsächlich.
AI.
Das ist bestimmt AI, oder?
Ja, steht da Agent.
Du meintest,
sein... Ja, wenn ich sage, mein Home Assistant
ist nicht im Internet. Das heißt,
von außen kannst du das Ding nicht erreichen.
Dass das Ding auf einem Server
läuft, der ins Internet kommt.
Das ist ja eigentlich standardmäßig so.
Es sei denn, du hast
das explizit ausgeschaltet und irgendwie
geblockt.
Was ist das denn?
Hyperframes? Walker?
Agent? Agent?
AI? Superbase?
Hyperframes
Write HTML
Render Video, Build for Age
Okay, alles klar
Heute ist ja alles KI
So Leute, es ist soweit
Affklo
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Bis in
3-4 Minuten
Benehmt euch, ich beobachte euch
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Vielen Dank.
Wieder am Start.
Ups.
Max, hat dein Klo eigentlich eine Statistikfunktion?
Leider, leider ist mein Klo zu alt in der Generation.
Die hat noch keinen Bluetooth-Schnittstelle.
Die neueren Klos von Geberit haben glaube ich eine Bluetooth-Schnittstelle, die kannst du auch mit der App pairen und sowas, dann kannst du sicherlich halt auch die mit einem eigenen Bluetooth-Dings pairen, wenn du dir anguckst, wie das funktioniert, ein paar Daten abgreifen, aber leider ist mein Klo zu alt.
das hat keine möglichkeit irgendwie daten davon abzugreifen das hatte ich also ich
hab's schon mal aufgemacht natürlich ja ich hab ich habe mein klo schon mal geöffnet und
da ist neben so eine platine drin das hat auch so was sieht aus wie ein seriellen anschluss drauf
aber was man damit machen soll ich habe ich habe auch irgendwann vor jahren mal auf github
hab ein bisschen gegoogelt, gesucht,
ob ich was finde, aber anscheinend
gibt's da nix zu.
Unraid 8.
Da hab ich ja noch gar nix von gelesen.
Was ist denn U-Core? Okay, das müssen wir
mal kurz lesen. U-Core
Unraid.
Unraid 8 announced.
70, okay, ist schon ein bisschen
näher, hab ich gar nicht. Wechselt von
Slackware zu Fedora.
Ja, endlich!
Endlich, Alter.
Der Slackware-Unterbau, der hat sich so antik angefühlt, Alter.
Endlich gehen die auf ein gescheites OS.
Sie hätten ja auch direkt auf Alma oder Rocky Linux gehen können für mehr Enterprise.
Das muss ich mir mal kurz angucken.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Unraid next chapter 1.
Also, okay, die labern oder?
Die labern oder sieht man nix.
Unraid 8 Fedora, sehr gut.
Waren die nicht mal bei Debian?
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, TrueNAS ist gewechselt von einem BSD-Kern zu, zu was?
Zu Debian?
Keine Ahnung.
weiß gar nicht
okay
immutable was wird das jetzt fedora mit nixos oder was
Okay, also man sieht noch gar nichts.
Weder Screenshots vom neuen UI.
Oder?
Gibt es denn überhaupt UI?
Irgendwas?
Naja, gibt nichts.
Ja, ich hoffe,
die aktualisieren das UI auch mal,
weil das sieht auch schon ziemlich altbacken aus mittlerweile.
Mal gespannt.
Mal gespannt. Also wie gesagt,
ich habe jahrelang
Unraid verwendet, einfach weil es
easy Lösung für daheim war
und alles das gemacht hat, was ich will.
Und ich habe auch noch zwei Lifetime Lizenzen.
Ich hoffe, mit einer Lifetime Lizenz
kriegt man das auch.
Wahrscheinlich werden sie
tricksen. Du musst jetzt abonnieren.
Naja, schauen wir mal.
Mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Warum ist hier...
Warum... Okay, okay, chat.
Warum ist hier ein grüner Punkt?
Ah.
Weil Visual Studio Code new ist.
Und das auch new.
Okay, nice.
Sehr schön.
Dann ist es halt new. Soll mir recht sein.
Okay, das Allerwichtigste.
Blazingly fast laser speed. Was trennt denn Rust?
Hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Hatten wir auch schon. RustFS.
S3. Ja, das ist das,
was viele Leute empfohlen haben auf Reddit.
Wenn man vorher
MinIO hieß das,
glaube ich, verwendet hat, sollte man jetzt
Rust... Keine Ahnung, habe ich noch nie. Ich habe mir noch keinen
lokalen S3-Storage bisher
gehostet. Ich wüsste auch gerade nicht so
genau, wofür.
WorkMux.
Das ist bestimmt auch KI-Stells, oder?
Zero Friction Parallel Dev.
Okay, anderes Wort für
Egentic Workflow.
Ja, siehst du auch hier schon,
Open Code läuft.
Rustesk Movie Box
Twee.
Terminal Interface
to find, download and stream movies.
Moment, Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das sind doch bestimmt nur
Sicherheitskopien, die hier runtergeladen werden, oder?
Das sind doch bestimmt alles nur Sicherheitskopien, die Relokal liegen hat, oder sehe ich das richtig?
Bestimmt, oder?
Mit Sicherheit.
Wobei man sich halt da fragt, warum man dafür unbedingt einen Terminal-Player braucht.
Ihr wisst, ich bin Terminal-Fan, aber das ist doch
Vibe-Coded, oder?
Rust, was sonst?
Ne, hab ich nicht mitbekommen.
Aber so beliebt kann auch Destiny 2
gar nicht mehr gewesen sein, wenn die es eingestellt haben.
Ja.
Bra Oxide.
KI-Stells.
Topgrade. Upgrade all things.
Was soll das sein?
Topgrade.
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was sehe ich da?
Es ist im Endeffekt ein Update-Skript,
was mehrere Updater
anwirft, oder was?
es macht dann quasi einen update upgrade dem upgrade plugins.net version
Okay, und was kann der alles updaten?
Kann der Arch, by the way, upgraden?
Nur weil es es für Arch gibt, heißt das noch nicht, dass es das auch upgraden kann.
Just run TopGear.
Config, Config.
und wo stellt man jetzt ein was der genau alles abtreten soll
die commands postkommand okay das ist ganz sinnvoll da kann man wenigstens
so ein snapshot machen vor dem update
hier kann man einstellen was er alles machen soll
composer linux mainpages und der kann auch repos updaten pulte dann master aus
windows.
Go, npm, ja,
deno.
Kann der auch
nuget, beziehungsweise
.net?
Rust.
.net kann er noch nicht. Ha.
She baited.
Okay, zumindest haben wir mal ein
cooles Projekt gefunden. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich es benutzen
werde, aber das ist doch mal was anderes,
als AI über AI, AI
über noch mehr AI.
Okay, warum gibt es hier...
Ist Hauri jetzt nicht mehr modern genug,
oder was?
Ne.
Moment.
Was bin ich hier sehen?
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Okay.
Irgendwelches
Umgehen von China-Chinesen.
Firewall-Geschichten.
Streaming-Services oder so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das brauchen.
A Clash-Metagui.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Clash-Verge.
Was ist?
Okay. Removed.
Keine Ahnung.
Bestimmt auch was um Sicherheitskopien zu schauen
Ether
Okay
Ich lese die Beschreibung und habe absolut keine Ahnung
Was das bedeuten soll
Arrest user space warp core
For sensor networks
Also auch irgendwas für die China Chinesen
Wobei
Wir sagen das immer so
Wir sind hier in der EU
Und in Deutschland auch auf dem besten Weg dahin
Was Zensur und Überwachung und vielleicht große Firewall angeht.
Man sollte da nicht immer nur so auf die Chinesen gucken und das belachen.
Das ist bei uns auch nicht mehr weit hin.
Vielleicht brauchen wir das demnächst auch alles hier.
A modern Linker in Rust.
Und warum?
Blazingly fast, laser speed.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Wir sind weit davon entfernt, findest du?
Also wenn ich so Sachen höre wie,
jetzt wird erstmal geguckt,
oder soll erstmal geguckt werden,
was, also Chat-mäßig Überwachung,
Dann sollen Social Media eingeschränkt werden mit Kontrolle.
Du brauchst natürlich eine zentrale Infrastruktur zur Kontrolle, wie alt die Leute sind.
Dann sind wir beim nächsten Mal.
Also nächster Step ist, wenn du eine zentrale Plattform hast zur Altersverifikation,
brauchst du ja generell eine Plattform zur Verifikation.
Heißt, als nächstes kommen Klarnamen.
Hast du den Talk zu dem Berliner Hack gesehen?
In China ist das nochmal...
Ja, sollen wir warten, bis es wie in China ist?
Wir sind eindeutig auf dem Weg dahin.
Wir können nicht immer sagen, ach, wir sind noch weiter von entfernt, wir sind noch weiter von entfernt, wir sind noch weiter von entfernt, wir sind noch weiter von entfernt.
Hoch! Jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr.
Du hast in China noch mehr Probleme, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass alles bis dahin okay ist.
Also wir sind eindeutig auf dem Weg dahin, was Zensur und Überwachung angeht.
Überleg mal, Leute hatten die Polizei vor der Tür stehen, weil sie auf Twitter einen Post gemacht haben und einen Politiker ein bisschen verarscht haben.
Dafür steht die Polizei vor der Tür.
Also man redet sich glaube ich teilweise ein, man ist weiter von China weg, als man das wahrhaben will.
Wir sind da auf bestem Weg hin.
Wir sind noch nicht da.
Ich hoffe auch nicht, dass wir jemals da hinkommen.
Den Talk
habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ich habe den Talk gesehen über...
Also den Talk habe ich aufgemacht schon für
wir wollen das mal gucken.
Über den Berlin-Hack.
In China entscheidet die Regierung
Ja, was ist denn hier?
Wie würdest du das hier bei manchen Sachen sehen?
Politiker beleidigt
Bam, Polizei steht vor der Tür
Wegen nichts und wieder nichts
Ja, wir sind noch ein bisschen von China weg
Aber ich glaube, wir sind näher dran, als man wahrhaben will
Oder wir sind zumindest
näher an dem Weg dran, als man wahrhaben will.
Und in einigen Bereichen sind wir auch schon da.
Also ganz unabhängig war das jetzt ja auch nicht.
Also offiziell natürlich schon.
Aber es gab ja einen Bericht
darüber.
Es gab einen Bericht darüber.
60 Minutes
irgendwo.
ja ja da hat irgendeine englische seite hat bei bei cbs news haben den artikel an den artikel
veröffentlicht die artikel darüber veröffentlicht wie das mit hausdurchsuchung hausdurchsuchung
teilweise läuft. Und da haben Staatsanwälte
dort gesessen, die gelacht haben
und haben sinngemäß sowas gesagt wie
die Strafe
der Hausdurchsuchung ist größer als das,
was die Leute eigentlich zu erwarten haben. Also quasi
Hausdurchsuchung als Strafe,
wofür es überhaupt nicht gedacht ist. Also das
wird schon teilweise echt mittlerweile ganz schön
verbogen,
was eigentlich nicht sein sollte.
Und in China
kannst du nicht einfach so berichten und
diskutieren und kritisieren. Das kannst du ja auch nicht.
das kannst du ja auch nicht
wie gesagt, ich sag nur der eine
der das Schwarzkopfbild gepostet hat
die Polizei am Start war
und
wir haben jetzt auch sowas am Start wie Trusted Flagger
Trusted Flagger
sind quasi besonders vertrauenswürdige
Leute
die Content
melden
also, wie soll man sagen, priorisiert Content
melden können
Also wie gesagt
Man darf nicht immer nur auf China schauen
Und sagen, haha, guck mal die Chinesen
Was die da machen, das könnte bei uns nicht passieren
Das ist bei uns
Auf dem Weg
Wenn nicht in manchen Bereichen
Auch schon da
Ja, ist auch so
Ja, der hat noch andere, aber da ging es ja dann
ursprünglich nicht drum.
Also, ich glaube, da müssen wir uns echt Gedanken machen die nächsten Jahre über.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns noch ein paar angenehmere Themen an.
Tja, da wäre ich auch dabei.
Das fände ich auch deutlich sinniger.
So was wie in Berlin nicht.
Das ist halt das Ding, wenn man sich so Sachen wie in Berlin anguckt.
Und dann hast du andere Projekte, wo es darum geht, immer mehr Daten zu sammeln.
Fängt mit elektronischer Patientenakte an.
Wobei ich der Sache sogar noch ein bisschen was abgewinnen kann.
Geht mit Altersverifikation und Klarnamenpflicht, den manchen Leuten vorschwebt, weiter.
Immer mehr Daten sammeln, aber nicht in der Lage sein, die Daten zu schützen.
Das ist halt der Witz, ne?
Teilweise gibt es für die Industrie und alles super krasse...
Was meint ihr, wie es im Finanzsektor...
Ich arbeite ja Frankfurt in der Finanzbranche.
Was es da im Finanzsektor für ultra krasse Auflagen gibt.
Ich habe ja davor bei einer Bank gearbeitet.
Das war noch schlimmer, Leute.
Da hast du Auflagen und Auflagen.
Es kommt jedes Jahr neues Zeug.
Und du hast auch Lauf- und Prüfer am Start.
Jeden Scheiß hast du da.
So Dinge, die du teilweise nicht mal richtig umsetzen kannst, weil sie so schwammig sind.
Du hast so viel Zeug, Alter.
Aber dann kommt Berlin an und speichert den Kram als Klartext-Excel-Dateien irgendwo.
Oder Klartext-Passwortlisten.
Also da ist halt die Frage so, traue ich denen allen wirklich zu, dass sie dann auch die Daten so ordentlich sichern, wenn sie sie dann haben? Also ich traue denen nicht zu.
Moin.
Du bist so ein 31er, hab im August die Ausbildung als Physi angefangen, im öffentlichen Dienst.
Aha.
Viele wurden nicht übernommen, ist das im öffentlichen Dienst auch so?
Ist das im öffentlichen Dienst so, dass viele nicht übernommen würden? Ich dachte, im öffentlichen Dienst kann man...
Wie sagt man so? Wie kann man sein Leben chillen?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wie das im öffentlichen Dienst ist. Kann ich überhaupt nichts dazu sagen.
Aber was... Gut, ich meine, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Was ist denn die ernsthafte Alternative, ja?
jetzt was anderes suchen mitten in der Ausbildung, ist doch auch blöd.
Dann mach lieber die Ausbildung ordentlich fertig.
Und du hast als Fisi immer noch was Zukunftsfähiges gelernt.
Überleg dir mal, du hättest irgendwie Marketing-Excel-Schubser gelernt.
Also wenn du was durch KI ersetzen kannst, dann sowas die nächsten Jahre über.
Fisi nicht unbedingt.
Also du hast auf jeden Fall die richtige Ausbildung schon mal gemacht.
Was so ist? Ja, es ist aktuell wohl schwierig als Junior halt frisch ausgelernt was zu finden.
Ne, umsonst war es ganz bestimmt nicht.
Du hast immer noch eines der zukunftsfähigsten Berufe gelernt.
Nur weil es da aktuell schlecht aussieht, heißt ja nicht, dass es bei der anderen Zwangsläufe so viel besser ist.
Und ja, es gibt sicherlich Jobs, die es in Massen aktuell gibt, wo da halt die Frage ist, will man die wirklich machen, ja.
Also ich denke mal in der Pflege und im Krankenhaus findest du für ein Apfel und ein Ei sofort was.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob man diesen Job wirklich machen will.
Ja, oder in irgendwelchen Handwerkerbetrieben, wo dir dann der Chef moins auf den Sack geht.
Keine Ahnung.
Also ja, es gibt sicherlich Berufe, die aktuell mehr gefragt sind und wo du mehr Sachen findest.
Aber ob du die wirklich machen willst, sei mal dann dahingestellt.
Also ich denke, Physi ist immer noch eines der besten Berufe, die man lernen kann aktuell.
Was hast du denn vorher...
Also ich meine, wenn du 31...
Ich meine, ich habe meine Ausbildung gemacht mit Paaren 20.
Da habe ich gedacht, ich bin ja auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Aber wir hatten auch, glaube ich, einen mit 40 oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie alt der genau war in der Klasse.
Was hast du denn vorher gemacht?
Also ich meine, vielleicht hast du jetzt ja den großen Vorteil,
dass du zwei Sachen kannst.
Und manchmal, manchmal gibt es ja so die Kombination an Unternehmen,
die bestimmte Jobs suchen, wo es super ist,
wenn man schon in dem Bereich quasi Vorkenntnisse hat.
Mir fällt jetzt, ja, keine Ahnung, ja, irgendwie,
Feuerwehr sucht irgendeinen ITler, ja, finden es natürlich nice,
wenn er sich im Vorfeld schon ein...
Na gut, das Feuerwehr ist ein doofes Beispiel.
Die haben... Das ist alles ehrenamtlich.
Oder das meiste. Bei den meisten zumindest ehrenamtlich, ja.
Also keine Ahnung, du bist ITler...
Wirst ITler am Flughafen
und hast vorher schon Erfahrung irgendwie
in der, keine Ahnung, Hotelbranche oder so.
Ja, es gibt schon manche Sachen, die sich überschneiden
und dann hast du nochmal extra, extra Chancen drauf.
Also die Ausbildung würde ich auf jeden Fall fertig machen
Also es dürfte immer noch eines der zukunftsfähigen
ITler im Krankenhaus
Ja, irgendwie sowas
Und du hast vorher schon Erfahrung gehabt
Du hast irgendwie mal
Eine Ausbildung zur Pflegekraft
Gemacht oder so, das bringt schon was
Ja, da hast du dann
Da hast du dann bessere Chancen
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eines der zukunftsfähigsten Ausbildungsjobs
So Ausbildungsberufe
die es aktuell gibt, meiner Meinung nach.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Ne, ich bin nicht afklo.
Musste gerade noch was gucken auf dem anderen Monitor.
Spezialisieren ist einfach.
Du musst erst mal rausfinden, dafür ist die Ausbildung ja sinnvoll,
musst erst mal rausfinden, welcher Bereich dir gefällt.
Ich meine, nur weil du was mit Computer gelernt hast, wie gesagt, meine Oma hat immer gesagt, machst was mit Computer.
Oder meine Mutter auch, denn die haben halt überhaupt keinen Zugang zu gehabt.
Dafür ist die Ausbildung ja gut, erstmal rauszukriegen, was man machen will.
Weil ich meine, es gibt so viele Bereiche.
Selbst wenn man nur mal High Level guckt, aber wenn man mal im Detail geht, das gibt ja alles.
Du kannst ja von übertrieben low-level Microcontroller-Programmierung bis zu Cloud-Architekt-Geschichten letztendlich machen.
Da ist ja alles dabei.
So, erstmal gucken, was einem gefällt.
Bei mir war das relativ einfach.
Ich habe mich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich die Ausbildung angefangen habe, schon sehr für Linux interessiert.
und fand es super, dass ich bei einem Internetprovider eine Ausbildungsstelle gefunden habe,
die hauptsächlich Linux-Kram machen.
So, ich habe da sehr viel gelernt, auch wenn die Ausbildung an sich echt beschissen war, Leute.
Ich hatte keine Ausbildung im eigentlichen Sinne.
Also wir hatten keine Ausbilder, die die Leute ausgebildet haben.
Das war ein Unternehmen, das hatte, ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt.
Ich weiß, Recycle-Story, aber kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Das war ein Unternehmen, das hatte 200 Mitarbeiter circa.
Und ratet mal, ratet mal, falls ich es nicht schon 500 Mal erzählt habe,
Ratet mal von den 200 Mitarbeitern, wie viel waren davon Azubis?
50, genau, 50.
50.
50 waren Azubis.
200 Mitarbeiter, 50.
Also ich kann euch jetzt nicht sagen, ob es 202 Mitarbeiter und 51 Azubis waren.
Aber ich weiß noch das Verhältnis.
200 Mitarbeiter, 50 davon Azubis.
Das heißt, die haben sich die Azubis eingekauft, weil die billig sind. Die hatten ja kleinere Rechenzentrumsstandorte in ganz Deutschland und da haben die einfach einen Server in den Kofferraum gepackt und haben zum Azubi gesagt, fahr das da hin, schließ das an, installiere einen Debian drauf.
und das war halt viel billiger
als das mit irgendeiner Spedition hinzuschicken
dann irgendeinen Techniker hinfahren
zu lassen oder whatever
also viele Azubis haben da nichts anderes gemacht
wie ihre komplette Ausbildung
irgendwelche Server quer durch Deutschland gefahren, angeschlossen
also es gab keine Ausbildung, es war bei mir auch so
also wir hatten keine Ausbilder
im eigentlichen Sinne, die gesagt haben
ey komm, lass uns mal das zusammen angucken
und dann gebe ich dir eine Aufgabe
und wir gucken uns das an, gab es nicht
Gab es nicht.
Also, ich habe fast nichts beigebracht bekommen.
Bei mir war das in der Ausbildung so.
Entweder hast du halt einfach mitgemacht und konntest alles lernen, was du lernen wolltest.
Oder du hast drei Jahre rumgegammelt und hast nichts gelernt.
Beides hat dich gleich viel interessiert.
Es war dir scheißegal.
Es war dir egal, ob du was gelernt hast oder nichts gelernt hast.
Es war dir egal.
Das hat dich nicht gejuckt.
Ich habe halt den Vorteil gehabt.
Ich konnte so viel rumbasteln wie noch nie mit Linux, auch in der Enterprise-Umgebung, damals auch bei einer Bank und so viel rumbasteln in der Enterprise-Umgebung und so viele Linux-Kisten am Start haben, wie ich das sonst nirgendwo anders hätte bekommen.
Wir hatten da teilweise zwischenzeitlich, haben wir uns mit einem kleinen Team von 4000 Linux-Server gekümmert.
Das waren damals auch echte Server und VMs.
Damals gab es, also gerade in der Ausbildung, hat man von Containern noch keiner geredet.
Das waren VMs und da war auch sehr viel Hardware noch dabei.
Ich weiß noch, eines der ersten, das hätte ich übrigens, glaube ich, gar nicht machen dürfen.
Ich war mal als Azubi dabei bei einem Nachteinsatz im Rechenzentrum.
Firewall-Upgrade
war das.
Da war ich zusammen mit einem anderen Kollege, den kannte ich schon.
Der hat das geplant.
Und das waren wirklich noch selbst
gebaute Firewalls. Das war ein
HE...
Ja, solche Dinger im Endeffekt.
Das waren
ein HE-Server.
So in dem Stil.
Ein HE-Server.
Mit einem Customized Read-Only Debian drauf.
Mit einem Micro...
Ne, nicht Micro SD.
Wie hieß der Kram damals?
CF-Karte.
CF...
Hier, so ein Ding.
Genau.
So ein Ding war da drin.
In den Servern.
Und das Firewall-Upgrade lief folgendermaßen.
Du musstest das runterfahren.
Du musstest es rausziehen aus dem Rack
Aufmachen, alte SD-Karte abmachen
Neue SD-Karte dran
Also die neue SD-Karte war quasi vorbereitet
Mit neuer Version
So, und
Dann wieder hochfahren
Und da waren wir nachts
Keine Ahnung, nachts um 2
Oder irgendwie so
Im Rechenzentrum und haben das gemacht
Als Azubi
WTF, Leute, ich glaube das ist
Rechtlich überhaupt nicht erlaubt
dass ein Azubi nachts um zwei irgendwelche
Dinger machen darf.
Ich glaube, das ist verboten.
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, das ist nicht erlaubt.
Hat aber keinen interessiert.
Naja, zumindest
habe ich das gemacht. Und da ist mir eins
passiert. Wir hatten
damals
ähm
Warte mal.
Mir fällt jetzt nicht
Ja, so sinnge...
Ungefähr so sahen die Dinger aus.
Ja, ungefähr so.
Nicht wirklich so, aber ungefähr so.
Wir hatten so Loadbalancer Firewall Appliance Dinger rumstehen.
Und da steckten vorne Module, Glasfasermodule drin.
Und da bin ich kurz bevor wir fertig waren, bin ich an dem Rack vorbeigelaufen.
und bin mit meiner Jacke
an den Glasfasermodulen hängen geblieben
und hab die rausgezogen aus Versehen.
Das hab ich gemacht.
Ich hab die Dinger einfach wieder reingesteckt
und so getan, als wär nix gewesen.
Und es ist nix passiert.
Ich hab aber echt ein bisschen Schiss gekriegt.
Nix passiert.
Es scheint gute High-Availability-Konfiguration
gewesen zu sein.
Wenn ich in meiner Lehre auch auf der Arbeit habe,
Was könnte ich am besten mit meinem Laptop machen, um mich weiterzubilden?
Deiner Meinung nach.
Linux.
Ohne Scheiß, Linux-Skills ist wichtig.
Windows, Windows-only.
Magst du Windows?
Willst du in der Zukunft in der Richtung weitermachen?
Dann kann ich dir wenig raten, weil ich habe absolut keine Ahnung von Windows.
Du hast wahrscheinlich doppelt, dreifach, vierfach, fünfmal mehr Ahnung von Windows als ich.
Ich habe keinen plassen Schimmer von Windows.
und mittlerweile bin ich auch auf einem Punkt, wo ich mich mit Windows gar nicht mehr großartig beschäftigen will,
wenn bei mir auf der Arbeit irgendwas mit Windows ist,
beispielsweise hatte ich letztens Software-Update auf der Arbeit, typische Windows-Geschichte,
automatisches Software-Update auf meinem Windows-Notebook, den ich vom Arbeitgeber gestellt bekomme,
Software-Update, Software-Update zwischendrin irgendwie abgebrochen,
dann war mein Zytrix-Agent weg, ich konnte nicht mehr auf meine Lieferungskiste, ich konnte nicht mehr arbeiten.
Einfach Zytrix Agent uninstall.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, guckst du dir das jetzt selbst an?
Nee, eigentlich keinen Bock.
Wahrscheinlich auch hast du keine Rechte.
Da habe ich bei unserer End-User-Support-Hotline angerufen.
Habe gesagt, Jungs, mein Zytrix ist weg.
Leider konnten die mir auch nicht helfen.
Die haben die üblichen verdächtigen Dinger gemacht, die man immer bei Windows Support macht.
Bitte leeren sie mal den Cache.
Bitte versuchen Sie das Öffnen in einem anderen Browser.
Und ich habe fünfmal gesagt, Leute, der Zitrix-Client ist nicht drauf.
Es ist egal, in welchem Browser ich das mache.
Ja, lassen Sie uns mal den Cache leeren.
Komplett useless.
Aber hat sich Mühe gegeben, war nett.
Hat dann ein Ticket aufgemacht bei den Zitrix-Leuten.
Und die haben noch irgendeinen Wartungslauf laufen lassen.
Und dann ging es.
Und wisst ihr, was die Lösung des Problems dann war?
Die Lösung des Problems war, ich musste, das stand wirklich,
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Leute, ich lese, Moment, Moment.
Ich gucke jetzt in meinem Outlook auf dem Handy, ob ich die E-Mail noch finde.
Nach was könnte ich ihn suchen?
Zytrix?
Oder besser nach...
Wartung oder sowas?
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Neustart vielleicht?
Ach, scheiße, das findet man nicht.
Outlook-Suche ist ja aber auch wirklich räulich, ne?
Outlook-Suche ist richtig beschissen.
Okay, Juni.
Wann könnte das... Februar.
Nee, Februar war das.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht habe ich auf die Mail geantwortet.
Gesendete Elemente.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Geil!
Mobiles Outlook lädt nicht mehr gesendete Elemente,
außer von einem Monat.
Top, nice. Okay, ich kann euch die E-Mail nicht vorlesen.
Zumindest stand in der E-Mail drin, ich soll nochmal Softwarewartung laufen lassen und dann dreimal neu starten, damit es wieder geht.
Habe ich gemacht, dann ging es.
Typische Windows-Scheiße, oder?
Erst random abgebrochen, dann irgendwelche sinnlose Fehlerfixes versucht wie Cache leeren und dann nochmal neu starten, die Updates und dann dreimal rebooten, damit es funktioniert.
Alter, was ein Schwachsinn, Windows-Kacke.
Mittlerweile setze ich mich mit dem Scheiß gar nicht mehr auseinander,
sondern lasse das einfach irgendwelche Leute machen, die davon mehr Ahnung haben.
Das liegt auch mit daran, ich habe gar keinen Bock, mich mit diesem Scheiß auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich kriege da immer Anfälle.
Allein schon, wenn ich irgendwelche Windows-Geschichten machen muss mal,
weil, keine Ahnung, ja, zum Beispiel, wenn ich mich auf ein ESX einloggen muss,
da muss ich übrigens so ein komisches Remote-Ding unter Windows, da kriege ich immer Anfälle davon.
Set-Servers ist eine gute Übungsseite.
Die haben wir im Stream auch schon gemacht.
Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Kannst du mit einem kostenlosen Account.
Kannst du dich, also musst du dich nicht.
Hier, guck mal.
Alles, wo Pro ist, kannst du nicht machen.
Aber alles andere kannst du machen.
Das sind Übungen.
Da bekommst du pro Übung.
Also ich würde erstmal die Easy-Übung machen.
Da bekommst du pro Übung eine kaputte Linux-VM.
Und die musst du wieder ganz machen.
Du hast dann auch einen Knopf, um zu überprüfen, ob das stimmt, was du gemacht hast und sowas.
Das ist super.
Also das ist super zum Üben.
Und ansonsten gibt es jede Menge YouTube-Content zum Thema Linux.
Und am besten ist eh, du installierst dir eine 4M, haust dir ein Linux drauf und benutzt das einfach.
Falls das möglich ist.
Ich weiß nicht, kannst du auf deinem Arbeitslaptop was installieren?
Weil dann kannst du vor allem eine Workstation installieren und Linux draufhauen.
Weiß nicht, ob das erlaubt ist bei euch.
Ansonsten, VM, ja, VM.
Kannst du, setz dir eine VM auf, installiere den Debian drauf.
Du darfst, ja, ja, dann.
Okay, wenn du ein eigenes Notebook verwenden darfst, dann zwei Sachen.
Installier dir, also es gibt mehrere Varianten.
mehrere Varianten. Entweder du holst dir
einen Mini-PC,
irgendwas Kleines, sowas, was ich ja auch am Start habe.
Also den gibt es jetzt nicht mehr, ja.
Ich habe hier so ein, da bin ich gerade drauf,
das ist das hier, ein Desktop, den ihr da gerade seht.
So ein Billigding.
Gibt es auch welche, die sind viel
kleiner, äh, nicht kleiner, meine ich,
also schwacher bestückt, ja,
und günstiger. Holst dir einen Linux-Mini-PC,
richtest den ein und
benutzt den daheim. Versuch das Ding
als Daily-Desktop
zu verwenden.
Dann lernst du auch richtig was. Oder aber
installiere dir vor allem eine Workstation,
habe ich hier auch am Start.
Ups, Moment,
zack, zack.
Oder installiere dir vor allem eine Workstation,
kostet in der neueren Version auch nichts
mehr und installiere dir eine Linux
VM.
Und versuch die Linux
VM und den Linux Desktop,
du kannst hier beispielsweise
installiere dir CacheOS,
habe ich am Start hier
auf der anderen Kiste oder installiert
einen Fedora mit KDE drauf.
Hast ja auch einen gescheiten Desktop. Und dann benutzt
einfach täglich
Linux, um zu arbeiten. Man lernt
enorm viel damit. Du kannst ja auch
einen Raspberry Pi holen oder einen Mini-PC
und darauf Debian installieren und ein bisschen
Server-Sachen üben und basteln.
Da gibt es tausend Möglichkeiten,
um Linux zu lernen. Das Wichtigste
ist erstmal anzufangen,
damit man überhaupt so ein bisschen Einstieg kriegt dazu.
So, das ist hier diese Kiste.
Sieht fast genauso aus wie das, was ich jetzt habe.
Das hier ist meine 4M.
Und die kannst du auch, die kann man auch wunderbar verwenden.
Du siehst daran, dass es eine 4M ist.
Weil hier da.
Aber die benutze ich nicht mehr,
weil ich habe ja jetzt mein
Linux Mini PC,
den ich hier laufen habe,
der fast genauso aussieht.
Archie ist ein bisschen viel,
deswegen sage ich, entweder CacheOS
oder Fedora oder Linux Mint.
Kannst dich aber ein bisschen schlau machen, was es gibt.
Da gibt es auf jeden Fall saumäßig viel zu lernen.
und Linux-Skills sind wirklich wichtig heutzutage.
Für was ich den Mini-PC benutze?
Ich benutze den Mini-PC für alles, wo sich nicht Windows anbietet.
Naja, du kannst spielen mal mit Linux ausprobieren.
Wenn du Sachen mit Anti-Cheat hast,
ist die Chance relativ hoch, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Aber so Daily-Sachen, ich weiß ja nicht, was du hobbymäßig machst.
Aber ich programmiere zum Beispiel mal ganz gerne Sachen.
das mache ich alles unter Linux
tägliche Sachen, was ich im Internet rumgucke
mache ich unter Linux
irgendwelches Skripten und Basteln
und Ausprobieren, Zeug mache ich unter Linux
ich arbeite auch auf der Arbeit auf einem Linux Desktop
da muss ich zwar Remote drauf, aber ich habe dann XFCE Desktop
also im Prinzip mache ich so gut wie alles unter Linux
was ich unter Windows mache ist
streamen, wie du hier siehst, da, streamen, spielen, Videos editieren, ich weiß, ich weiß, YouTube-Videos, und Thumbnails erstellen.
ja die haben keine plan die haben absolut kein plan das sind irgendwelche 60 jährigen windows
admins die auswendig wissen was du hier in die alte cmd shell eingeben muss um irgendwelche
active directory rollen profile whatever vergiss es vergiss es linux ist eines der meiner meinung
noch eines der wichtigsten physik skills die es gibt mein eindruck ist und chat ich weiß nicht
ob das stimmt ich habe keine ahnung ob das stimmt ja aber mein eindruck ist dass im in den meisten
größeren business sachen die server unter wind und unter linux laufen was was unter windows läuft
sind natürlich alle Clients, ja, irgendwelche
Active Directory-Geschichten.
Aber ich kann es nur, okay, ich kann es nur
von meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber
und von meinem letzten Arbeitgeber
sagen. Also, letzter Arbeitgeber
war eine Bank.
Aktueller Arbeitgeber ist eine Versicherung.
Wir haben
90% Linux-Server.
Und 10% Windows-Gedöns
für Kram, das halt nur unter Windows geht.
Ja, das kommt auch dazu. Vieles geht halt
schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht unter Windows.
Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob es nicht irgendwie doch geht.
Aber die Frage ist, warum sollte man das machen?
Ja.
Aber Linux ist wichtig.
Gut.
So.
Dann lass uns doch mal schauen.
Ja und?
Das ändert doch nichts daran, wie viel Linux-Server wir haben.
Ich könnte auch im Business Enterprise Umfeld
Excel-Dateienkopierer sein.
Aber habt ihr Juniors bei euch?
Ja.
Wir haben erst letztens einen frisch ausgelernten Azubi ins Team gekriegt.
Linux.
Der wollte auch explizit, hat er während seiner Ausbildung gesagt,
zu uns und wollte Linux machen.
Und wir suchen sogar gerade jemand,
ein Junior Storage Admin.
Was sollte so ein Mini-PC kosten im Durchschnitt?
Du kannst doch irgendwas Gebrauchtes nehmen.
Weiß ich nicht, musst du mal gucken.
Du kriegst bestimmt für 200 Euro schon was Brauchbares.
Bist du eigentlich immer noch der Best Ager?
Dieses Wort habe ich außer im Vorstellungsgespräch nie wieder gehört.
Mein Vorstellungsgespräch hatte ich mit 38.
Ja, ne? 38.
Mit 38 hatte ich mein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Das war 2022.
Mit 38 hatte ich das Vorstellungsgespräch.
Und da meinte der Personaler zu mir,
sie sind ein Best-Ager.
Ab 40 ist man Old-Ager.
Und was ist man dann ab 60?
Vorrentner-Ager.
Der Jüngste?
Nee, ich bin nicht der Jüngste im Team.
Wir haben drei Leute, mittlerweile ist es so, wir haben drei Leute im Team, die jünger sind als ich.
Einmal der Ex-Azubi, dann ehemaliger Kollege, den ich tatsächlich noch vom alten Arbeitgeber kenne, der mich auch dahin gebracht hat.
Weil der gesagt hat, sag mal, Max, willst du nicht zu uns?
Hab ich mir die Stellenanzeige angeguckt, hab ich mir gedacht, doch, klingt nicht schlecht.
Und noch ein anderer Kollege. Also drei sind jünger als ich.
Im Team.
Also eben Linux, Linux Team
Und ich glaube
5 oder so sind älter als ich
Also ich bin so ziemlich in der Mitte
Gerade
Ja, weil es Kack-Noobs sind
Die irgendwelchen Microsoft-Only-Shit machen
Sobald du ernsthaft irgendwas hosten und betreiben willst
Linux, beste
Außerdem, und selbst wenn nicht
Selbst wenn nicht, bist du einfach
deutlich breiter aufgestellt, wenn du noch Ahnung
von Linux hast.
Wie viele sind bei dir im Windows-Team?
Gute Frage.
Fünf?
Frage Zeichen.
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Also Linux sind mehr Leute
auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, Linux sind wir 9.
Wie alt bist du?
42.
Jetzt.
Seit ein paar Tagen bin ich 42.
Ja.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Was sind denn heutzutage die Jobs, die man guten Windows-Skills macht?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung von Windows.
Das musst du Sorry fragen.
Kennst du da besser aus?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe wirklich, ich habe keinen blassen Schirm davon.
Also weder von Windows, noch von Windows-Skills und Jobs.
Also ich glaube, okay, okay, eine Sache, eine Sache.
Ich glaube, es gibt die Möglichkeit, wenn du Windows gedönst,
wenn du windows erfahrung hast gibt es glaube ich die möglichkeit das wissen
ganz gut auf manche services zu transferieren
also du kannst wahrscheinlich wenn du windows ahnung hast auch es hat active
directory wobei es ja active directory nicht mehr echte verleger heißt sondern
entra id wobei haben wir das jetzt nicht noch mal umbenannt heißt es jetzt nicht
wieder anders
Oder heißt es noch Entra-ID?
Ach, jetzt heißt das Windows Admin Center?
Nee.
Okay, nee, es heißt immer noch so.
Okay, es heißt immer noch so.
Aber ansonsten kein
Plastenschimmer von Windows.
So Leute, falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt,
sagt Bescheid. Ich kann jetzt nicht die ganze
Chat hochscrollen.
Ah ja, den Windows-Skill
habe ich auch.
Einmal neu starten. Hat Windows
immer noch diese Zertifizierung? Ja,
ich hab mal, beim alten Arbeitgeber
hab ich eine Azure-Schulung
mitgemacht.
Azure Admin
901, gab es
sowas?
warte mal, Azure
Azure 901
ja sowas
ne, das ist exam.ai
äh, Azure
äh, admin 901
ok, mittlerweile heißt das
heißt das AI 901, keine Ahnung
ich hab mal so ne komische, so ne komische Azure-Schulung
mitgemacht, weil, nicht weil ich da Bock
drauf hatte, weil mein alter Arbeitgeber
gemeint hat, das müssen wir alle
das müssen wir alle jetzt wissen und
deswegen, so da haben die sich irgendeinen Trainer, also
die Microsoft-Schulung, also die haben sich irgendeinen Trainer
organisiert, der das halt anbietet, die
Microsoft-Schulung sind einfach
beschissen. Der Trainer kann sich nicht
hinstellen und euch was zeigen und mit euch was
machen, diese Microsoft-Schulung müssen
weltweit nach dem gleichen Schema laufen.
Die haben vorgegebene PowerPoint-Präsentationen
von Microsoft, die der Trainer
mehr oder weniger durchklickt und vorliest.
Und die Übungen,
die übung dies dazu ja da pennt man wirklich an die übung dies dazu gibt sind auch richtig
richtig brain dead hängen geblieben also wenn ihr also ich habe wie gesagt in der ich kann nur für
diese schulung sprechen aber ich glaube diese microsoft schulung sind alle gleich und zwar
da gibt es eine powerpoint präsentation die wir durchgeklickt der trainer labert dazu und dann
gibt es so einen sohn und übungs so einen übungs lab und übung würde man sich ja eigentlich
vorstellen okay mal angenommen man kann man mal angenommen man hat in dieser in
dem letzten kursabschnitt hat man gelernt wie man den erster vor allem
aufbaut ja also resource group erstellen public ip reinpacken vor allem rein
packen und was auch immer schon lange her das was er schon gemacht habe
also das kann die aufgabe ist erstellen sie eine ubuntu vm die so und so
erreichbar ist und namensauflösung hat so würde man erwarten dass die aufgabe
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Die Übung bei Microsoft sieht folgendermaßen aus. Und das ist kein Witz, das ist wirklich so. Mal gucken, ob es da Beispiele für gibt. Nee, gibt keine Beispiele für. Gut, so sieht Azure aus. Gibt keine Beispiele für.
Zumindest, die Übung sieht so aus, du hast rechts, glaube ich, ist es, die Anleitung.
Und, also wie gesagt, normalerweise würde man sagen, zum Üben kriegt man halt die Aufgabe,
erstellen Sie eine Ubuntu-VM mit DNS-Namensauflösung und so und so erreichbar.
Und danach guckt der Trainer halt nach, ob man es ordentlich gemacht hat.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Diese Microsoft-Übungen laufen folgendermaßen.
Klicken Sie jetzt oben links auf das Hamburger Menü.
Schritt 2. Gehen Sie nun auf Virtual Services.
Fahren Sie an der Registerkarte entlang und öffnen Sie das Menü Virtual Machines.
Klicken Sie jetzt oben auf Virtuelle Maschine erstellen.
Klicken Sie jetzt, ohne Scheiß, du musst in dieser Übung, keine Ahnung, 130 Punkte anklicken.
und durchmachen
alles wirklich
braindead, einzelner,
also du lernst nichts, du lernst
wirklich gar nichts.
Du lernst vielleicht auswendig, wo du klicken musst.
Und diese Dinger sind natürlich auch regelmäßig
outdated, weil
das GUI in Azure sich ändert.
Dann muss der Trainer immer sagen, ach ja,
dieser Punkt heißt jetzt übrigens nur noch VM und nicht
Virtual Machine. Richtig hängen geblieben.
Und von Hörensagen,
ich habe nie so eine Azure Prüfung
dann gemacht. Vom Hörensagen her
sind die Prüfungen genauso kacke.
Die wollen dann von dir
wissen, die wollen nicht von dir wissen, wie du eine
VM erstellst. Die wollen von dir wissen,
dass du dafür in das
Little Machines Menü
musst und dann in die
Registerkarte Create
und dann auf das Plus klicken und sowas.
Richtig hängen geblieben. Also diese
Microsoft-Schule kommt komplett
für den Arsch. So, was haben wir denn hier
Schönes?
Warum immer das jetzt in Chrome aufgeht?
Schlimmer, oder was, was schreibt denn der CCC hier?
Schlimmer als Stopp, Schilder versehen hat der EU.
Och nein, nicht schon wieder.
Alter, könnt ihr uns mit dem Scheiß nicht in Ruhe lassen.
Australien macht das ja schon.
Übrigens, ich finde die Benahmung so toll.
Das liest sich so, als soll hier was zum Schutz der Kinder gemacht werden.
Ein Scheiß geht's denen um den Schutz der Kinder.
Ja, wenn die wollen, dass es den Kindern gut geht, sollen die mal ein paar Lehrer einstellen vielleicht.
Und noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Gucken, dass es ordentliche Kindergartenplätze gibt.
Und nicht so durch die Hintertür Altersverifikation und Kontrolle für alle einführen.
Australien macht das, semi-erfolgreich.
In Australien, also ich habe gelesen, in Australien, als Australien das eingeführt hat, ich weiß nicht, ab 15 ist es in Australien, oder? Wo du auf Social Media darfst.
Bin ich sicher.
keine ahnung ist auch egal zumindest in australien ist da wo das eingeführt wurde
oder ab 16 da wo das eingeführt wurde ist die sucheanfragen nach anonymen internetzugang vpn
und so sprunghaft angestiegen und ein nicht unerheblicher teil der jugendlichen unter 16
australien benutzt heute social media halt über vpn also lass lass uns mal kurz überspringen das
Das ist ein ganz schön langer Artikel, aber wir gucken mal kurz.
Also, lesen wir mal.
Die EU-Kommission hat einen Entwurf zum EU-Kids-Act vorgestellt.
Er bedeutet nichts Gutes für die Zukunft des freien und fairen Internets.
Ja, das habe ich mir jetzt auch nicht anders vorgestellt.
Anstatt Kinder wirklich zu schützen...
Wer hätte sich das nur denken können?
Bedeutet er das Ende jeglicher digitalen Teilhabe für Jugendliche unter 18?
Einen tiefen Grundrechtseingriff für alle und eine Gefahr für alle...
By the way, da muss ich mal sagen, ich finde generell,
diese Geschichte mit
man muss das jetzt für Jugendliche einschränken,
komplett weltfremd.
Komplett weltfremd.
Du kannst doch nicht einer Generation,
die mit
Handy, Tablet,
Social Media aufgewachsen
ist,
das omnipräsent
ist in ihrem Leben,
einfach sagen,
nein, dürfte nicht mehr benutzen.
Nein.
Natürlich suchen die sich alternative Wege
Und sicherlich
Ist es
Besser es gibt eine offizielle
Also ne
Sie suchen sich dann irgendwelche shady Wege
Über keine Ahnung
Komische VPN Anbieter
Und was auch immer
Ich finde das so
Ich finde das so weltfremd
Die Frage, die sie hätte, kommt, also VPN-Einschränkung, das kommt bestimmt dann auch noch irgendwann, zumindest hat einer von denen schon die Idee gehabt, gehe ich stark von aus.
Die Frage ist ja schon alleine, was zählt denn jetzt eigentlich als Social Media?
Facebook? Wahrscheinlich.
LinkedIn? Dürfen wir wahrscheinlich eh keine Karte haben.
Weiß ich nicht. Instagram? Keine Ahnung.
Twitch? YouTube? Ist das so?
Keine Ahnung, das kann man da schlecht...
Okay, wir lesen es.
Ja, Whatsapp, Snapchat.
Gerade, gerade.
Roblox. Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Roblox.
Ich glaube, Roblox ist aktuell
so ziemlich das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
Wo sich irgendwelche pädophile Leute rumtreiben.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
da nicht Social Media.
Ist Roblox wirklich
so schlimm? Keine Ahnung. Ich habe in meinem Leben
noch nicht einmal Roblox installiert.
Zumindest muss es da abgehen in Roblox.
Und wahrscheinlich auch in Minecraft oder sowas.
Roblox ist Fiebertraum.
Und YouTubes, ja, okay.
Also, da geht's zur Sache zurzeit.
Okay, also, mit dem EU-Kids-Act hat die EU-Kommission am 17. September 2007 eingesetzt.
Ah ja, auch mal wieder zwischen Tür und Angel hier wahrscheinlich.
Zur Beschränkung des Zugangs von Social-Media-Plattformen für Kinder.
By the way, wir hatten es doch hier eben gerade erst, wo die Leute gesagt haben, ach, ach, ach, China, das ist doch alles.
Ich sage euch, wir sind eindeutig auf dem Weg.
Und in manchen Bereichen sind wir auch schon da.
Ähm, vorgelegt.
Der vorgestellte Entwurf schreibt strenge Regeln für Social Media, Videoplattformen, Online-Spiele, Chatbots sowie Software-Marktplätze.
For the fact, du hättest Kinder und Jugendliche und 18 praktisch keine Möglichkeit zur digitalen Teilhabe mehr.
Das betreffe außerdem auch alle Personen, die im Alter nicht nachweisen können.
ja darum geht's also darum geht's wir brauchen eine zentrale plattform zur zur identitätsfeststellung
im endeffekt was ja der nächste schritt ist einfach brauchen alle plattformen zur
altersverifikation wir brauchen alle plattformen zur identitätsfeststellung wir müssen das eine
oder das andere machen ja was machen denn dann die ganzen streamer wo gefühlt irgendwie 80
prozent der zuschauer irgendwelche jugendlichen sind die haben dann gelitten
guckt da keiner mehr zu die gucken halt einfach über vpn zu so sprecherin des
ccc warnt wir sollen eine regulierung bekommen die tief in die grundrechte
aller eingreifen sich nur an big tech orientiert ja gut die muss natürlich
weiterhin fettkohle machen so werden nur die größten big tech konzerne bestand
haben können alternative angebot ja gut das kann ich mir gut vorstellen weil die
Auflagen, die gemacht werden, nicht von jedem
erfüllt werden können.
Discord, ist auch eine Frage. Was zählt
Discord?
Okay, Altersfeststellung
für alle und Überwachung durch Eltern.
Das geplante Gesetz bedeutet für Kinder und
Jugendliche einen vollständigen Ausschuss vom
öffentlichen Online-Diskussion. Wie gesagt, ich finde
das mega
weltfremd. Das ist die, guck mal,
die Generation, die ist aufgewachsen
mit Tablet und Handy, die ist aufgewachsen
mit Livestreams,
YouTube, Instagram,
äh, äh, Messengern
Discord
Du kannst doch jetzt nicht einfach sagen
dass das, was das
was das heißt, sie sind damit aufgewachsen
Das ist für die normale
Omnipräsenter quasi
Lebensbestandteil
Das ist so, wie wenn die
für irgendwelche Boomer sagen
würden, sie dürfen nicht mal
Musikantenstadel gucken, nur noch
deutlich mehr, ja
Das ist so, wie wenn du zu einem Boomer sagst
er darf kein Fernsehen mehr gucken.
Vom Umfang her.
Wenn du jetzt zu irgendeinem
Rentner gehst und sagst,
ab heute zum Schutz für dich
darfst du kein Fernsehen mehr gucken.
So ist das für die.
Die sind komplett weg. Die gucken kein
Fernsehen mehr.
Die leben im Internet.
So, okay.
Okay, lass mal weiter gucken.
Vollständig Ausruf vom öffentlichen
Disonanbm. Dabei soll die
Registrierung zum Spießrutenlauf werden.
Für Kinder und unter 15
Jahren soll es auf Social Media
und Videoplattformen sogenannte Eltern
Accounts geben.
Diese setzt voraus, dass sich die Eltern... Ja, geil!
Da müssen sich die Eltern auch verifizieren.
Im Prozess der Registrierung müssen dann sowohl das Alter
der Eltern als auch... Okay.
Realistisch betrachtet, realistisch betrachtet, ne?
Das macht ja keiner.
Die Eltern legen einen Account an, die Kinder benutzen ihn.
fertig.
Elternverifikation
bedeutet Ausweis hochladen.
Gesicht. Ausweis hochladen.
By the way.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitgekriegt habt.
Revolut
hatte ein Datenleak.
ist eine litauische
Bank, glaube ich.
Da wurden Ausweisfotos
und Identifikationsfotos
geklaut.
So, und wo wir beim Thema sind, ne, vorhin.
Überlegt euch mal.
Berlin hat so richtig reingeschissen.
Und wollen wir wirklich diesen Leuten trauen,
mit einer zentralen Plattform zur Altersverifikation?
Oder wollen wir unbedingt, dass Google und Instagram,
also Meta muss man ja sagen,
dann auch noch unsere Ausweiskopien haben?
Ist das wirklich so? Wollen wir das unbedingt?
Das schafft die selben Rieslinge wie die Kindersaltersprüfung, zentrale Datensprechung, Identitätstipstahlrisiko und den Ausschluss von Familien ohne passende Dokumente wie etwa Patchwork-Familien, Pflegeeltern oder Familien ohne offizielle Papiere.
Einmal eingerichtet ermöglichen solche Accounts Eltern einen tiefen Einblick in die Privatsphäre.
Ja, das ist ja das nächste.
Kannst übelst spyen, was deine Kinder machen.
Kinder unter 15 Jahren müssen in Zukunft ständig Sorge haben, dass ihre Eltern jeden Klick nach jedes Bild mitlesen.
Ja, finde ich auch nicht gut.
Schlimmer noch, jedes Kind muss sich durchgehend beobachtet fühlen.
Ja, und an das Gefühl gewöhnt ständig überwacht.
Vielleicht ist das ja sogar gewollt.
Vielleicht ist das ja sogar gewollt, dass man quasi das Gehirn schon darauf vorbereitet.
Das ist normal.
Weiter setzt dieser Vorgang voraus, dass eine positive Beziehung zwischen Eltern und Kindern besteht.
Bei fehlerhafter Bereitschaft, einen Eltern-Account anzulegen, werden Kinder direkt ausgeschlossen.
Ich wette mit euch, da wird die Fakes werden übelst zunehmen.
KI-generierte Ausweise, irgendwelche Services, die dir einen Account machen, gegen shady Sachen und so.
Das birgt so viel Potenzial wieder, dass da drumherum irgendein Ökosystem entsteht mit so halblegalen Dingern.
Okay.
Unklare technische Umsetzung. Ja, wie bei so vielen solcher Sachen.
Während für Social Media und Videoplattformen die Nutzung der EU zur Verfügung stellen, all das Nachweisplattformen...
Ja, geil, sowas, ne?
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Wir sind auf dem besten Weg, es den Chinakinesen nachzumachen.
Vorgeschrieben ist, bleibt die technische Lösung für alle anderen Angebote weit offen.
Das Vorschreiben von sogenannten Zero-Knowledge-Proofs, ich war zu dumm, das zu lesen,
Zero-Knowledge-Proofs für alle weiteren Lösungen ist irreführend, denn an anderer Stelle werden Plattformen Zugriff auf öffentliche Geburtenregister,
Selbstaufkünfte von Eltern sowie Nutzer von Daten, um die Eltern-Kind-Beziehung zu bestätigen, als Lösung vorgegeben.
Das genaue Gegenteil von Zero-Knowledge-Proofs.
Ja.
Ich bleck's ja dankeschön für den Sub.
Im schlimmsten Fall könnte es zu einer umfassenden Datensammlung mit Geburtsurkunden ähnlichen...
Ja, könnte es, wird es.
Diese pro Plattform erzeugten Daten halten Bergen die bekannten Probleme für den Datenschutz und für die Sicherheit der gesammelten Daten.
Einerseits wird Big Tech unter dem Deckmantel des Kinderschutzes...
Können die dann sagen.
Ja klar, die können sagen, wir halten uns ja nur an Vorgaben.
Ein weiterer Strauß an Informationen zur Anreicherung ihrer Dossiers über jeden und jeden in den Schoß geworfen.
Andererseits werden einige Anbieter dieses lästige neue Problem an die günstigsten Drittanbieter.
Ja, genau, genau.
Grundsätzlich gilt, Altersfeststellung online ist stets mit zentralisierter Infrastruktur verbunden
und birgt daher eine Gefahr für anonyme und pseudonyme Internetnutzung.
Ja.
Und ich kann es auch oft genug sagen, es ist enorm wichtig, dass das Internet anonym oder pseudonymisiert benutzt werden kann.
Weil ansonsten kannst du freie Meinungsäußerung vergessen.
Die als solche eine unabdingbare Voraussetzung für die Wahrnehmung wesentlicher Grundrechte ist.
Trotz ernster Warnung vor den Konsequenzen einer solchen nie dagewesenen Überwachungsinfrastruktur
stellte die EU-Kommission das Gesetz ohne die sonstigen üblichen Folgenabschätzungen vor.
Ja geil, ja klar, da wird ja eh zur Zeit rumgetrickst as fuck.
Die Abstimmung war ja schon komplett an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Also, nee, nicht an den Haner beigezogen.
Also komplett abenteuerlich, wie die Abstimmung zur Chat-Kontrolle gelaufen ist.
So am letzten Tag, wo alles schon weg war, nochmal außer Dings was einberufen.
Ganz großes Kino, ja.
Beam, danke schön für den Sub.
Dies zeigt nicht nur fehlendes Problembewusstsein für die Implikation einer solchen Infrastruktur,
sondern eine grundsätzliche Verweigerung der Beschäftigung mit negativen Konsequenzen, ja.
Gefahr für Big Tech Alternativen.
Die Einführung einer flächendenkenden Altersverstellung würde alle Alternativen zu Big Tech und die Open Source Community besonders hat.
Ja klar, die haben nicht die Ressourcen und die Technik, um das zu leisten.
Ich meine, überlegt euch mal. Wisst ihr schon, was es für ein Riesenakt war, die Diskussion,
dass in System D, oder wo das war, ein Schalter eingebaut werden sollte,
oder nee, nee, nee, das stimmt nicht, kein Schalter, ein Feld hinterlegt werden sollte, wo das Alter drin steht.
Das hat zu wochenlangen Diskussionen geführt, ja.
Was meint ihr, was da erst los ist?
Ich spiele mein altes MMO gerade nicht.
Wenn die neue Season anfängt, habe ich da wieder Bock drauf.
Denn der EU Kids Act bietet kaum Ausnahmen.
Zwar sollen Enzyklopädie wie Wikipedia und Open Source Software wie Codeberg ausgenommen sein.
Ja, ist Codeberg schon Social Media?
Nicht jedoch dezentral soziale Netzwerke auf Open Source Basis wie Masterdoor und App Store.
Ja, wisst ihr was? Ich sehe da, vielleicht ist es keck Alu, ich sehe da noch was anderes durchblicken. Die hat natürlich, die EU und alle Machthabenden, da haben wir natürlich keinen Bock auf dezentrale Plattformen. Warum? Weil man dezentrale Plattformen viel zu schlecht überwachen kann, viel zu schlecht ausschalten kann, viel zu schlecht kontrollieren kann.
Mündigkeit statt Bevormundung.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon öfters gesagt.
Einer der ärgerlichsten Aspekte am EU-Kids Act ist, dass einzelne technisch fragwürdige Maßnahmen behandelt wird, als könne sie ein komplexes gesellschaftliches Problem lösen.
Doch Erziehung und das Erlernen digitaler Mündigkeit lassen sich nicht in Realitätsführende Bürokratie-Montage vorgehen.
Exakt so ist es.
Kinder und Jugendliche müssen wie im analogen Leben lernen, riskante Situationen zu erkennen, korrekt?
Ja, vor allem überlegt euch mal, ne?
Stellt euch mal vor, jemand ist bis 18 Jahren gesperrt, hat keinerlei Social Media Erfahrung, nichts.
Ab 18, wo er dann übrigens auch voll strafdingsmündig oder wie man das nennt, ist und mit allem haftet, ja?
Ab da wird er dann auf die Welt Social Media losgelassen und lässt sich vom jeden dahergelaufenen Depp scammen, weil er keine Ahnung davon hat.
Geil, oder? Super.
und damit vor allem kleinere Anbieter belastet, ist dafür kaum ein Ersatz.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Die Verantwortung muss außerdem dort aufgezürrt werden, wo sie größte Gestaltungsmacht und somit Verantwortung liegt, bei den Big Tech Plattformen.
Zudem ist die Schlussfolgerung inakzeptabel, dass technische Schutzwerkzeuge zwangsläufig zu Überwachungsinstrumenten werden müssen.
Das Gegenteil wäre richtig. Gute Mechanismen sind möglich, so kahl anzusiedeln, als auf Identitätskarten, dem Gerät oder im Betriebssystem.
Sie sollten transparent für das Kind und gemeinsam mit der Familie auf freiwilligen Bein...
Okay, das ist sehr vage, keine Ahnung, was das genau bedeuten soll.
Damit können Familien unterstützt werden, auf vereinbarte Grenzen, statt auf heimliches Tracking zu setzen und Anlässe für Gespräch statt permanent Kontrolle zu schaffen.
Daher fordern wir überall dort, wo Altersnachweise oder besser noch Alterseinschätzungen tatsächlich erforderlich ist, eine Prüfung, ob diese nicht auf dem eigenen Gerät erfolgen kann.
denkbar wäre etwa ein Machinismus, bei dem das Betriebssystem eine App lediglich mitteilt, welche Altersstufe, ja, das wäre sinnvoll,
für ihren Nutzer relevant ist, ohne dass die Plattform dafür die Identität eines Kindes oder seiner Eltern kennen muss.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe es ja schon gesagt, es geht nicht zum Schutz der Kinder, dann sollten Sie sich mal überlegen,
was in Roblox so abgeht, warum die Leute keine Kindergartenplätze mehr finden oder die Schule nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Du kannst vieles machen, um Kinder zu schützen, vieles Sinnvolle machen, um Kinder zu schützen.
Das ist vorgeschobene Überwachung letztendlich. Einführung von Überwachungsmöglichkeiten.
Ganz klar, Kinder brauchen Schutz, online und offline. Aber sie brauchen ebenso die Chance, mündig und kompetent zu werden. Ja, genau. Eine gute europäische Digitalpolitik sollte deshalb beides zusammen... was zusammen... denken. Verbindliche Verantwortung für die Plattform war aber auch technische Schutzmaßnahmen und niederschwellige Hilfe.
Darüber hinaus müssen wir die Fähigkeiten junger Menschen schärfen, sich in der digitalen Welt selbstständig und sicher zu bewegen.
Das wäre Jugendschutz, der nicht auf Vormundung, sondern auf Mündigkeit.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon oft gesagt.
Und überlegt euch mal wirklich, wenn das Beispiel eintritt, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Jemand hatte bis 18 Jahren keinen Kontakt mit Social Media und auf einmal jetzt, wo er voll selbsthaftbar ist mit allem
und voll zur Verantwortung gezogen wird mit allem, was er macht.
Jetzt wird er darauf losgelassen und ist vollkommen verloren.
außerdem, außerdem, und ich kann es nochmal sagen
es ist komplett weltfremd
die Leute, die das jetzt bedenken, die sind
damit aufgewachsen, die leben im
Internet, die gucken kein Fernsehen
mehr
und setzen sich abends vor die Tagesschau
die sind
auf Twitter, auf Reddit, auf
Discord, auf WhatsApp
auf Snapchat, auf
Instagram, auf allen möglichen Plattformen, wo man
halt so ist, in Roblox
in Minecraft
Ja, die sind online am Start.
Das ist schlimmer, als wenn du einem Boomer sagen würdest, er darf ab heute kein Fernsehen mehr gucken.
Das ist ein Teil des alltäglichen Lebens, wird entfernt.
Nein, die Kinder, die Generation ist glaube ich nicht mehr so wirklich Fortnite.
Also hier geht es ja so um die Generation, keine Ahnung, so...
So, ab wann fangen denn Kinder heutzutage an mit Smartphone und Tablet?
Mit 8 oder so? Keine Ahnung, 8, 9?
Ja, so 2. Generation, 8 bis 18 trifft das ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Fortnite großartig spielen.
Oh Mann, ich muss schnell wieder zumachen, sonst reg ich mich noch weiter auf.
Zubi.
War das nicht so, dass das
meistgespielte Game des letzten
Jahres, war das nicht
sogar irgendein Roblox
Mod, wo man irgendeinen
Garten baut oder so?
Ich hab noch nicht weitergemacht.
Ja, hab ich mitbekommen. Das war doch was, oder?
Roblox
Garten-Game.
Keine Ahnung, wie das heißt. Crow Garden, ist es das?
Keine Ahnung, ja?
Das ist das, was die Kinder von heute
spielen.
Wobei es wahrscheinlich auch schon wieder outdated ist.
Das war das meistgespielte Game letztes Jahr.
Sowas.
Auf sowas, auf sowas hier.
Was immer das ist.
Das, da gehen die ab drauf.
9 Millionen Likes einfach.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es das ist, ja.
Meist gespielte Game, ich glaube 2000, äh nicht 2023, 2025.
Throw a Gun, ja.
Es brach alle Rekorde für gleichzeitige Spieler.
Komma
Juli erreicht das Spiel
21,9
Millionen
Gleichzeitiger Spieler
Also wer denkt
Ja
Das World of Warcraft zu seiner Hochzeit viel war
Das hier ist hoch
Irgendein komisches
Roblox Garten Game
Alter
Und wer weiß, wie viele Pedos sich da rumtreiben
In Roblox
Die schwimmen im Geld wahrscheinlich
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung habe
Wie
Die
Wie nennt man das so?
Also der Weg ist, wie man Geld verdient mit Roblox Erweiterung.
Keine Ahnung.
Für die Erweiterung selbst oder durch Ingame Verkäufe?
Okay, ja, keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funzt.
Tja.
So sieht's aus.
So, wir wollen uns aber eigentlich das Video angucken hier.
Lidl gegen Amazon, weil der Chat sagt, das wäre ein bisschen cringe.
Schauen wir mal, ob das cringe ist.
Meine Meinung dazu habe ich vorhin schon gesagt.
AWS gibt es seit 2006.
dass Lidl seit den paar Jahren, wo es das gibt, nicht wirklich mit Amazon mithalten kann, muss man sich nicht wundern.
Die hatten einfach noch nicht genug Zeit.
Es ist zumindest schon mal kein deutsches oder EU-Projekt, dann wäre das von Anfang an zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Lidl versucht und Lidl hat zumindest so, wie ich das über Dreiecken mitbekomme,
wir haben auch einen kleinen Versuchsaufbau in der Lidl-Cloud, da fehlt wirklich noch viel.
Ich benutze das selbst nicht. Ich höre das immer nur von Leuten, die da mit gerade Sachen evaluieren bei Lidl.
Beziehungsweise bei Schwarz, muss man ja eigentlich sagen.
Nee, Stack It heißt, gell? Stack It heißt, glaube ich.
Aber die geben sich Mühe.
So viel kann ich da raushören, ja.
Okay, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Was macht denn Lidl so?
Alter, die Intro-Musik, ey!
Goodbye Silicon Valley.
See you later.
Alter, was ist das für cringige Aussprache? Da kriege ich ja jetzt schon Kotzreflex.
US Tech Elite.
Diesen Sommer zündet Europa den IT-Boost.
Alter, das klingt ja...
Zukunft.
Made in Landkreis Heilbronn.
Also nicht hier.
Okay.
Alter, was ist das für nervige Musik dabei?
Versuchen Sie, den Zoomer unter uns anzusprechen.
Alter, auch die Schnitte, die machen mich fertig.
So, noch Fragen?
Also ich hatte noch Fragen, einige sogar.
Bin nach Bad Friedrichshal gefahren und hab mir das ganze Teil einfach mal angeschaut.
Ist laut genug?
Passt so?
Ist das jetzt hier das neue deutsche Silicon Valley und warum sollte ausgerechnet Lidl sowas
hier überhaupt hinstellen? Okay, es ist nicht Lidl selber, sondern die Schwarzgruppe, der Lidl
Mutterkonzern und der war in der Vergangenheit nicht sonderlich bekannt dafür, sich gerne die
Karten schauen zu lassen. Man agierte lieber im Verborgenen. Umso mehr bin ich froh, dass es
geklappt hat mit einer Drehgenehmigung. Für einen halben Tag dürfen wir uns heute anschauen, was
die da drin eigentlich machen und ich muss los, denn ich hab da einen Termin. By the way, nochmal,
was mir gerade einfällt.
Ich habe ja gerade gesagt, irgendwie 21 Millionen
Leute, das sind ja nur
die, die diese eine Erweiterung waren
bei Roblox, nicht Roblox insgesamt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viele Spieler Roblox hat.
Was
ist eigentlich?
Also ich kann es mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
weshalb man
Roblox spielt.
Es ist ja kein Game
im klassischen Sinne, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Also es ist ja
kein Battlefield.
Es ist kein Alus G3 oder so. Es ist kein in sich abgeschlossenes Game. Es ist ja mehr oder weniger, so von dem was ich gelesen habe, ist das ja irgendwie so eine Art Plattform, so eine Art Engine, inklusive App Store, in der man quasi Games programmieren und anbieten kann.
Also man könnte quasi ein Battlefield in Roblox bauen.
Was ist denn der Reiz davon?
Also warum ist das so beliebt?
Wahrscheinlich, weil es free ist und keine Altersbeschränkung.
Okay, vielleicht, ja.
Fragt mich das echt?
Ich habe noch nie, also ich wüsste gar nicht, wie man sich da einloggt.
und die Frage ist halt auch
ist das dann, kommt das
Game halt mit
wird das mit was mitgeliefert
mit irgendwie so einer Multiplayer Hub World
oder sowas
wo man dann im Game
die einzelnen Spiele launcht
so ein bisschen wie Mario 64, wo man in die
Bilder springt
ich hab echt keinen blassen Schimmer
und irgendwie hab ich auch keinen Bock das auszuprobieren
Egal, gucken wir das Video weiter
Okay
Ist halt die Frage bei dieser ganzen Social Media
Geschichte, die wir eben gerade gelesen haben
Würde da Roblox auch drunter fallen?
Man weiß es nicht, ne?
Wahrscheinlich haben die sich die Leute, die Gesetze machen
oder die Vorgaben machen, selbst noch keine Gedanken
darüber gemacht
Okay, auf geht's
Wenige Schritte später
Also wir sind in, wo sind wir überhaupt?
Gebäudeteil
Sind wir komplett lost
Wir sind ins erste Parkhaus reingefahren, ehrlicherweise
Leider komplett falsch
Direkt verlaufen
Also nochmal auf Start
Moment, das stimmt schon mal überhaupt nicht. Das muss ja schon mal gefakt sein. Woher hat er denn seine Zutrittskarte? Der muss ja schon mal an der richtigen Stelle gewesen sein.
Der Laden ist riesig und ich bin froh, als ich meine Verabredung endlich finde.
Hi. Hallo. Du bist Joanne. So ist es. Hi, Sebastian. Schön, dass du da bist. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Sehr gerne.
Krass, ihr plant groß.
Wir planen durchaus groß, ja. Es sind tatsächlich 15,5 Hektar, davon ca. 8 Hektar Graufläche und 7,5 Hektar Grünfläche.
Besorgt euch schon mal Zettel und Stift, das waren nicht die letzten Zahlen.
Joanne führt mich heute hinter die Kulissen von Schwarz-Digits. Ohne sie komme ich nirgendwo hin.
Nur wenige durften hier zuvor überhaupt drehen.
Am 25. August 2021 fand quasi der Spatenstich statt.
und im Januar diesen Jahres sind dann die ersten Piloten, also die Test-User eingezogen.
Pilotensacken?
Was? Eingezogen?
Ist nicht der Sinn von einer Cloud, dass man nicht vor Ort irgendwas machen muss?
Piloten, so nennen wir das hier in unserer Tech-Sprache.
Und quasi dann im April diesen Jahres sind wir in Wellen in das neue Home of Digits eingezogen.
Das ist ein bisschen der Hintergrund.
Okay, wo wart ihr vorher?
Also ich war vorher in der Schönbeinstraße. Die Schönbeinstraße, das ist quasi das Inkogniturbüro im Kauflandparkhaus.
Im Kauflandparkhaus waren die Headquarters.
Ja, richtig. Das war früher mein Bürostandort. Also total knuffig eigentlich.
Und jetzt schon richtig voll. Also gerade ist aufgemacht und jetzt ist schon Vollbetrieb.
Total, ja. Also wir haben hier wirklich sehr, sehr viele Kollegen am Standort.
Wir hätten theoretisch ein Fassungsvolumen von 5.500 Arbeitsplätzen.
In Summe sind wir bei der Schwarz Digits 8.500 Mitarbeitende.
Und wir haben, glaube ich, 2800 feste Arbeitsplätze und der Rest gestaltet sich quasi ganz nach dem Motto New Way of Working.
Blablabla, haben Sie irgendeine Marketingfrau hingestellt, die jetzt erstmal voll loslegen darf, wie geil sie alle sind.
Wir haben Kreativräume, wir haben große Besprechungsräume.
Ihr merkt schon, Joanne kann präsentieren. Hand aufs Herz.
Für viele ist das Büro ein Ort mit einem Ambiente-Score zwischen minus 5 und minus 95.
Der Platz, wo man seine acht Stunden zwischen Filterkaffee und Raubfasertapete absetzt.
Das ist hier deutlich anders.
Was passiert da hinten?
Das sind tatsächlich die Welcome Days, die hier gerade parallel stattfinden.
Das sind quasi unsere Newbies, die hier heute ganz frisch starten und auch Teil des...
Okay, man hört schon an der ganzen Aufmachung, die wollen halt so ein bisschen Fang-Kultur vermitteln, könnte man sagen.
Ja.
... auf Digits werden.
Das heißt, Sie haben heute Ihren ersten Arbeitstag?
Korrekt. Erster Arbeitstag wird begonnen mit einer Führung über diesen fantastischen Campus.
Okay. Was sind das für Leute? Das heißt, was machen die jetzt beruflich?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Tatsächlich ist es hier super divers.
Also wir haben von den IT-Lern und Entwicklern, die quasi selbst an der souveränen KI und Cloud für Europa mitarbeiten,
bis über die klassischen Bürotätigkeiten, Vertrieb, Marketing, die Controller etc.
Das heißt, ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, in welchen Bereichen sie erstarten, aber in einem dieser Bereiche werden sie sich befinden.
Das heißt, wie bei jeder großen Firma, das gibt eigentlich zig Berufe, die sozusagen dort sind.
Ganz genau, ja.
Später wird mir Jeanne natürlich noch erzählen, was sie hier eigentlich macht.
Das ist also unser Terrasse. Umfasst nochmal 400 Plätze.
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor.
Ja, wick, wick. Letzten Motto. Da sind wir quasi heute Morgen reingekommen.
Also du kommst ja hier, hast verschiedene Eingänge von der Autobahn halt auch aus und dann ins Parkhaus.
Und jetzt darf ich dir noch etwas für mich im ersten Augenblick Kurioses bis Geniales präsentieren.
Das ist unser Schlafraum. Also das gibt es auch.
Ja, bei Google in Frankfurt haben die auch, aber keine Ahnung.
Also Schlafraum weiß ich nicht, aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir was unterschrieben haben, dass wir nichts erzählen, ich weiß nicht.
Quasi in jedem Aufenthaltsbereich, da kann man direkt...
Egal, ich sag's trotzdem, die haben so einen eigenen Konsolenraum.
Wobei ich mich da halt frage
Ist er nur da
Zur Zierde
Oder spielt da auch wirklich jemand Konsole drin
Weil das ist so ein bisschen
Okay das ist ein bisschen unfair
Das miteinander zu vergleichen aber
Es gibt ja so viele
Oldschool mittelständische Unternehmen
In Deutschland die einen Tischkicker irgendwo stehen haben
Und da steht eigentlich nur da
Nie spielt einer damit
Das dient einfach nur dazu bei Führungen
den Leuten zu zeigen, oh guck mal, wie viel Spaß wir haben. Wir haben sogar einen Tischkicker.
Oder am ersten Tag die Leute mal da kurz ranlassen.
Auch mal eine Mittagspause verbringen, wenn man total erschöpft ist.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, ernsthaft.
Ich glaube, viele Firmen kennen den Schlafraum, er heißt nur so.
Kann das auch gut sein, ja. Aber durchaus. Das ist unser Napping-Raum.
Das gefällt mir sehr, sehr gut auf jeden Fall.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Anregung für meinen Arbeitgeber. Ich finde, so ein Schlafraum ist...
Haben wir auch auf der Arbeit, witzigerweise.
Es gibt so einen Ruheraum.
Da ist ein Fernseher mit Kaminfeuer drin.
Hat grüne Sofas.
Ich habe mich noch nicht reingelegt.
Keine Ahnung, wie bequem das ist.
Wir haben sogar einen Raum.
Also, die haben ja bei uns auch voll aufgerüstet.
Ja, bei uns merkt man auch, dass sie so ein bisschen modernen Vibe versprühen wollen.
Wir haben sogar einen Raum mit mehreren Kaffeeautomaten drin und daneben hängen Schaukeln.
Da kannst du dich in eine Schaukel setzen und Schaukeln beim Kaffee trinken.
Ja.
Schaukeln.
Wie gesagt, die wollen auch ein bisschen so modernen Flair versprühen, ja.
Okay, kurzer Break. Ich hoffe, es kommt ansatzweise rüber, wie krass das da drin war.
Also das ist eine...
Bis jetzt hat man noch gar nichts gesehen.
Völlig andere Welt, Parallelwelt würde ich fast sagen.
Und ich habe ehrlicherweise nicht gedacht, dass sie überhaupt existieren könnte.
Also nicht in Baden-Württemberg.
Wohnen denn die Leute auch da wie bei Google?
Bei Google ist es doch auch irgendwie so, also gut, in Deutschland weiß ich nicht, aber in den USA ist es doch auch irgendwie so,
dass die eigene Wohnsiedlung quasi haben, also im Prinzip leben und arbeiten die Leute für und bei Google.
Sorry, Halbron, auch nicht in Halbron.
Also als ich gedreht habe, hatten ja 90 Leute gleichzeitig ihren ersten Arbeitstag.
90 Leute, die an einem Tag frisch eingestellt wurden.
und Joanne hat mir erzählt, als sie ihren ersten Tag hatte,
waren es 300 andere.
Das Ganze mal nur vor dem Hintergrund, dass ein paar Kilometer weiter...
Naja, wenn die da erst frisch eingezogen sind
und frisch in der Region sind oder so, dann brauchen die
Manpower.
RF-Programmer?
Nee. Keine Ahnung.
Gerade die Autoindustrie abschmiert.
Gehört sich auch nicht.
Jetzt denkt, glaube ich, jeder bei
der Schwarzgruppe sofort an Lidl und Kaufland
und nicht unbedingt an sowas hier.
Also ich denke da mittlerweile auch dran ist das nicht heißen sie nicht stacket oder so stack it needle
Ja genau die hier was sind die
Auch ob man die haben eine neue webseite chat
Ist es jetzt an oder aus die webseite ist neu es ist nicht mehr dieses komische komische gelb
sondern eine webseite
Mit fehlenden Logos.
KI-generierten Hintergründen wahrscheinlich.
Aber es ist mehr oder weniger noch die gleiche Webseite, nur dass die Farbe jetzt anders war.
Vorher war diese Farbe, das war so komisches Gelb vorher, die Webseite.
Naja.
Warum? Ja, warum?
Ja, warum? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Tatsächlich, weil Lidl und Kaufland eben auch digitale Lösungen benötigen,
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor. Das ist zu viel Marketing, bla bla. Ich hoffe, da kommt erst gleich noch was Technisches.
Und das sind unsere eigenen Customer Zero, weil wir vertesten quasi erst unsere digitalen Lösungen selbst, bevor wir sie dem externen Markt anbieten.
Das heißt unabhängiger sein von den großen Tech-Konzernen.
Genau, Unabhängigkeit ist die Vision dahinter. Wir wollen digital souverän agieren können, auf Augenhöhe mit unseren Partnern und selbst entscheiden können,
wo wir unsere Daten speichern, mit wem wir arbeiten und jederzeit eben auch die Fähigkeit zu haben und die Stärke zu haben, von einem Verhandlungstisch aufstehen zu können, wenn die Bedingungen nicht mehr passen.
Okay, kurz zusammengefasst. Eigentlich entwickeln sie IT-Lösungen für ihre Supermärkte. Aber was schon mal entwickelt ist, das kann man auch anderen Firmen verkaufen. Wir gehen da später nochmal ins Detail.
Ich glaube ja nicht, dass die nur für Supermärkte entwickeln und das dann weiterverkaufen. Also ich glaube, der Zug ist abgefahren. So war es ja bei Amazon am Anfang auch. Amazon hatte sehr viel ungenutzte Kapazitäten. Sinngemäß, wir machen AWS.
Die werden sich garantiert daran orientieren, was der Markt so nachfragt. Auch wenn die das im Supermarkt nicht brauchen.
Dann sind wir hier schon unterwegs. Zeit für einen Kaffee.
Okay, so kann offenbar eine Kaffee da aussehen.
Willkommen in Bits and Bites, der schwarze Dittitz, unserem Betriebsrestaurant.
Nennen wir es mal Betriebsrestaurant. Vielleicht muss das hier alles auch so aussehen.
Was mich jetzt interessieren würde, kostet das Essen was? Ist es subventioniert? Und wie ist es so?
Wenn man tausende Fachkräfte irgendwie nach Heilbronn locken will, denke ich mir.
Das Video ist nur Werbung bis jetzt.
Dass so dein Arbeitsplatz ist und nicht einfach irgendwie ein Büro mit Topp-Pflanze, Rauchfasertapete und das war's.
Ich muss ja jetzt schon sagen, ich arbeite ja schon etwas länger, als es den Campus gibt.
Das heißt, ich komme ja ursprünglich aus einem kleinen Büro.
Für mich war das in den Anfangswochen fast etwas nostalgisch, weil ich dachte, huch, auf einmal 15,5 Hektar, auf denen du hier irgendwie deinen Tag verbringst.
Von so einem kleinen süßen Büro. Ich würde sagen, jetzt, ich schätze es einfach unglaublich wert, das ist ein Privileg hier arbeiten zu dürfen.
Also man gewöhnt sich sehr schnell dran. Das ist ein gewöhnungsstil. Das heißt jetzt würde ich sagen, ist es mir durchaus wichtig. Damals war es aber fast etwas überwältigend.
Stichwort überwältigend. Bislang war von den angeblich tausenden Mitarbeitern nicht allzu viel zu sehen. Das ändert sich jetzt. Mittagspause.
Man merkt schon, jetzt lebt das Ganze irgendwie. Total. Jetzt passiert was. Total. Und hier kannst du dir quasi wie bei Maccas das Ganze bestellen.
Also wenn du drauf klickst.
Okay, das finde ich cool. Das haben wir bei uns in der Kantine leider nicht.
Bei uns in der Kantine kann man nur im Vorfeld auf einer Webseite gucken, was es gibt. Wo es das gibt.
und kann dann halt gezielt hin.
Du siehst auch, was es kostet und so.
Das finde ich cool.
Das sind definitiv subventionierte Preise.
Also ich würde sagen, bei uns sind die Preise
ungefähr auch in diesem Bereich
vielleicht so für so ein Chili,
vielleicht ein bisschen günstiger.
Bei uns würde das Chili wahrscheinlich eher so irgendwas 4,20 oder so kosten.
aber insgesamt ist das denke ich mal recht vergleichbar wir haben ja auch mehrere kantinen
sieht man ja auch hier ja einmal diese diese pasta und pizza kantine und jetzt hier dieses
robo ich habe vergessen wie es irgendwas mit robo hieß das jetzt hier also bei uns auch mehrere
kantinen also wir haben wobei ich erzähle euch nicht so viel sonst könnt ihr einfach nachgucken
Dennis, danke schön für den Zap.
Hast du hier quasi die Menüauswahl, siehst du auch alle Genen und alles,
kannst du einsehen und dann kannst du da quasi dir ein Gericht auswählen.
Und dann kommt das Ding.
Ja, dann wird das Ding gekocht, genau.
So, ich glaube, ihr habt es gesehen, also mit Lidl hat der Tech Campus natürlich überhaupt
Haupt nichts zu tun, so wie vieles, was Lidl macht, nicht unbedingt was mit Lidl zu tun hat.
Also streng genommen ist Lidl auch nur ein Teil der Schwarz-Gruppe mit ihren fünf verschiedenen Sparten.
Der Konzern gehört mit rund 186 Milliarden Euro Umsatz allein 2025 zu den größten deutschen Unternehmen
und ist weltweit einer der mächtigsten Handelskonzerne.
Der jute alte Lidl.
Mehr als eine halbe Million Leute arbeiten für Schwarz.
An dessen Spitze steht er und er hat einen Namen, den ich nicht aussprechen kann.
Gerd Chrzanowski.
Okay, jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen Technik rein.
1973, ich mache die erste Filiale in Ludwigshafen auf.
1973 erst?
Ich hätte gedacht, die gibt es schon länger.
...unabhängig sein und zwar von externen Lieferanten, von deren Lieferketten und von deren Preisen vor allem.
Lidl sagt also, egal ob Cola oder Schokoriegel, cleverer als Einkaufen ist doch selbst machen.
So, und dieses Prinzip kann man natürlich ausweiten und weiter treiben.
Recycling und Entsorgung kann man selbst machen.
Alter.
Warum sind die Videos mittlerweile so?
Ich weiß, ich bin zu Boomer dafür wahrscheinlich.
Natürlich eine Datencloud.
Braucht natürlich Cyber Security.
Braucht natürlich eine KI-Lösung.
Und auch das alles.
Es schließt sich der...
Ich hab das Video kaputt gemacht.
Mit Spulen.
Goodbye, silly.
Und was man nicht vergessen darf, was auch echt ganz gut mit dabei ist, Alibaba.
Also wenn man das mal so weltweit guckt, die China-Chinesen.
Die sind auch ganz gut im Cloud-Game mit dabei.
Und die Daten da wirklich zu jeder Zeit sicher sind.
Ja, ich kann es machen, ich kann es nicht machen.
Niemand weiß, was ich tun werde.
Die Schwarzgruppe setzt da also lieber auf sich selbst.
Mit Erfolg.
Also die Ambitionen in der Schwarzgruppe und auch bei Schwarzdigits sind echt ziemlich groß.
Wir müssen ihnen ordentlich Geld in die Hand, auch für neue Rechenzentren.
Ich war auch selbst in Brandenburg, in Lübbenau mal.
Das ist echt ein großes Teil, was da entsteht.
Und das soll natürlich auch mit dann die Infrastruktur sein.
Und ja, sie erhoffen sich natürlich auch was davon.
Irgendwann ist natürlich mal die Grenze erreicht, wie man auch mit sozusagen Lidl und Kaufland,
also wo wirklich das große Geld dann auch verdient wird, wie man da...
Ja gut, das stimmt. Das ist endlich.
...weiter wachsen kann. Und deswegen ist es natürlich logisch, sich als Schwarzgruppe zu überlegen,
wie können wir mehr Geld verdienen und auch noch in welchen anderen Sparten.
Also die haben doch wirklich finanziell was davon, jetzt in diesen Bereich reinzugehen.
Na, ob die jetzt schon finanziell großartig was davon haben, wage ich mal zu bezweifeln. Aber das ist natürlich der Plan langfristig.
Das kann man sagen, wenn das alles so klappt, dann auf jeden Fall. Also die Margen im Cloud-Geschäft sind in der Regel nochmal deutlich größer als in diesem hart umkämpften Lebensmitteleinzelhandel, in dem sie sich ja gerade zum Beispiel mit Lidl und Kaufland seit ganz, ganz langer Zeit schon befinden.
Okay, ist da jetzt Freeway-Cola drin?
Nicht ganz. Im Herzen sind natürlich auch wir Händler. Also haben wir natürlich die klassischen Saskia-Flaschen aus dem Wiel hier.
Ganz real, ja. Aber okay, Coca-Cola ist es. Warum auch nicht?
Cola, immerhin. Das Gebäude nimmt einfach kein Ende. Ein Bereich will mir Joanne unbedingt auch noch zeigen.
Das ist wie so ein Audi-Max. Ja, so kann man sich das fast vorstellen.
Also das ist jetzt quasi der Mediensaal. Das ist der flächenmäßig größte Raum.
Irgendwie erinnert die mich ein bisschen an Emma Watson, bloß in blond. Weiß ich, was es ist.
Also gewisse Ähnlichkeit hat die.
Und Platz mit für bis zu 500 Personen.
Hier hat Joanne auch schon mal eine Rede vor versammelter Mannschaft gehalten.
Denn ihr habt's gemerkt, Joanne zählt eher zum Mitarbeitertyp maximal ambitioniert.
und sie hat auch schon einiges erreicht.
Leitet das digitale Souveränitätsprogramm und...
Das digitale Souveränitätsprogramm.
Also eins kann ich euch sagen, bei uns, wenn es so ein Programm gäbe,
wäre das nicht so ein kurzer Name.
Bei uns würde das deutlich länger heißen und hätte eine kryptische Abkürzung.
...Deals ein mit Anfang 20.
Was immer wichtig ist und das bedeutet digitale Souveränität für mich persönlich auch...
Okay, jetzt kommt ein auswendig gelernter Satz.
Das Thema Freiheit. Also schlichtweg Freiheit.
Das hatte ich sich nicht on the fly ausgedacht. Das hatte ich schon 500 Mal erzählt.
Freiheit zu haben, im digitalen Raum frei zu agieren und auch zu bestimmen und zu entscheiden, mit wem möchte ich arbeiten, wo liegen meine Daten und mit wem gehe ich Partnerschaften ein.
Das ist richtige Karriere-Crinderin. Die hat das passende Crinset-Mindset.
Es kommt ja darauf an, was ist mein eigener Anspruch.
Was heißt da Freiheit für dich? Also wo ist man unfrei?
Finde ich geil, die hat jetzt zwei Sätze gesagt, die so absolut nichtssagend waren.
Wenn deine ganze Umgebung von genau einer Gruppe, einer technischen Lösung abhängig ist und es sehr schwierig ist zu wechseln, genau dann bist du halt unfrei.
Gut, deswegen wechselst du jetzt zu Lidl, um nicht da zu wenden, Lock-In.
Ja gut, das stimmt. Aber denen macht der Lidl auch keine Konkurrenz.
Die machen ja kein eigenes YouTube, kein eigenes Twitch, kein eigenes LinkedIn, Instagram oder sowas.
Das geht eher um Alternativen zu Cloud-Anbietern.
Und das werden die meisten Leute unwissentlich vielleicht nutzen.
Joanne sagt, auf genau diese Challenge hat sie extrem Bock.
Warum bist du jetzt ausgerechnet hier gelandet?
Ja, also ich muss sagen, ich habe hier die ziemlich seltene Chance, an der digitalen Souveränität von Europa mitzuarbeiten.
Okay, auch wieder schön auswendig gelandet. Aber gut, ey, du musst das erzählen, was die Chefs natürlich hören wollen, ist ja klar.
die kann nicht sagen,
boah, das war ein richtig, richtig nicer
Schritt, hier hat man mehr zu sagen und verdient mehr Kohle
und außerdem verspreche ich mir,
noch weiter aufzusteigen und noch mehr Kohle zu verdienen
und noch mehr Einfluss zu haben. Das kannst du natürlich nicht
sagen, da musst du halt irgendwas
vorschieben.
Rico, ich hab
irgendwann am Anfang des Streams
mich heute lang und breit über KI ausgelassen.
Das mach ich jetzt nicht nochmal.
Aber Entwickler
werden nicht ersetzt.
...schauen, wie andere etwas aufbauen...
Entwickler werden deutlich effektiver.
...selbst eben aktiv das Ganze...
Aber bis es so weit ist, dass eine KI,
also dass jemand, der keine Ahnung hat und das nicht versteht,
eine App über mehrere Jahre weiterentwickelt
mit reinem Vibe-Coding oder Agentic Engineering,
der von der Technik keine Ahnung hat,
das sehe ich auch die nächsten Jahre nicht.
...gestalten und tatsächlich Verantwortung übernehmen.
Moin Hans Wurzt.
Es ist schon ziemlich besonders, etwas proaktiv mitzugestalten
und von vornherein mit in diese Denkprozesse reinzugehen
und etwas aufzubauen, was gerade erst entsteht.
Das ist schon schön.
Ey, guck mal, so ähnliche Monitor haben wir auch.
Sieht fast genauso aus.
Und, oh ne Mist, wir haben Steckdosen,
die sehen auch fast 1 zu 1 genauso aus.
Wir haben Tische, die sehen fast 1 zu 1 genauso aus.
Kann das sein, dass bei uns die gleichen Berater das Bürokonzept designt haben wie bei Lidl?
Für diesen Job ist sie extra von NRW in die Region gezogen, erzählt sie mir.
Der Campus sei inzwischen ein Magnet für Fachkräfte, höre ich.
Okay, hier ist dann ein Reich sozusagen.
Genau, hier ist quasi mein Reich. Hier auf der Seite befindet sich mein Büro.
Man sieht keine Leute, also scheint es Homeoffice-technisch auch ganz gut zu klappen.
Oder sie haben einfach noch nicht genug Leute.
Das ist quasi meine Homezone hier und ich habe hier auch einen fantastischen Ausblick.
Bestimmt Wechselarbeitsplatz auch.
Das ist glaube ich gerade nicht ganz so sichtbar durch den Sichtschutz, aber das ist quasi
mein Büroplan.
Das heißt, es gibt nicht nur Großraumbüros, oder?
Richtig, richtig.
Also es gibt quasi diese klassischen Büros, es gibt aber auch Meetingräume, es gibt hier
diese netten Telefonzellen.
Also hier kannst du dich quasi
für auch mal vertraulich...
So was hatten wir bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Ich habe die Dinger gehasst.
Wir haben einfach jetzt bei uns
jede Menge Rückzugsräume, wo immer irgendwo was
frei ist. Außerdem sind bei uns
ganz viele Leute im Homeoffice. Du hast da ganze Büros,
die leer sind. Da kannst du dich einfach schnell reinsetzen,
wenn du mal vertraulich telefonieren musst.
...Spräche in so einen relativ
kleinen Raum setzen, ist tatsächlich
auch klimatisiert.
Es sieht vielleicht ein bisschen
nett und gemütlich aus und da kann man dann mal das ein oder andere vertrauliche gespräch führen
und schwitzt nicht komplett an was aber die jetzt im moment ein beispiel sicherlich an sehr vielem
spiel ist unser european sovereigns texten das ist ja unser erst drei programm und unsere grundsatz
der nickt so alles klar ich verstehe voll was du sagst was vision ist es den industriestandard für
digitale Souveränität in Europa damit zu setzen. Alter Marketinggelaber!
Zeig's dir gerne mal. Das ist quasi die digitale Ansicht dessen und da machen wir
digitale Souveränität tatsächlich messbar. Das heißt, ich kann als Unternehmen checken, wie gut bin ich aufgestellt?
Wie souverän bin ich? Ja, es gibt zwei Tools. Das ist quasi dann das...
Okay, das ist für irgendwelche Managementleute, um schöne Grafiken zu haben.
haben ist drei lenz damit kann ich meine gesamte infrastruktur bewerten und da eine
souveränität scorecard entwickeln die frage ist halt wieso für ihn bist du wenn du jetzt
all in zu lille gehst ja okay da bist du nicht mehr abhängig von aws aber wahrscheinlich ist
es genauso schwierig von lidl weg zu weg zu weg zu wechseln ja du hast paar andere
datenschutzbestimmungen also potenziell ist das schon besser
aber so souverän so wie man ich glaube man verkauft da mehr als eigentlich ist und hier
mit bewertet also mehr gefühl als man eigentlich kriegt einen konkreten service also eine anwendung
kannst du wirklich die infrastruktur deines gesamten unternehmens mit messen und bekommst
dann quasi aus ja moment moment moment die infrastruktur die bei lidl ist
Hey, ich bin 80% souverän und das muss ich tun, um digital souverän zu sein.
Klingt nach den Themen der Zeit. Nur für mich immer noch ungewöhnlich, das alles hier zu hören.
In einer Kleinstadt nördlich von Heilbraun.
Aber machen wir uns nichts vor. Natürlich wollten die Leute von Schwarz-Digits auch, dass wir diese ganzen nice und shiny Wow-Momente einfangen und verbreiten.
Ach, da wären wir gar nicht drauf gekommen.
Okay, hat funktioniert. Bringt mich aber auch zu der Frage, wie viel PR steckt hinter dem Anspruch, Europa digital souverän zu machen.
Es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen PR dabei. Es macht vor allem aber auch interessanterweise nicht nur schwarz Digits, sondern viele europäische Unternehmen haben digitale Souveränität als Verkaufsstrategie für sich entdeckt.
Am witzigsten wäre, wenn das irgendein europäisches Unternehmen verkauft und unter der Haube letztendlich AWS resellt.
Das ist auch ein Modebegriff und auch eine Projektionsfläche für ganz viele verschiedene Ängste und Probleme.
Und das funktioniert gerade sehr gut als Buzzword, weil man irgendwie ganz viele unterschiedliche Zielgruppen damit ansprechen kann und dahinter vereinen kann.
Und das machen sehr viele Akteure auch strategisch.
Also man muss natürlich auch immer sehen, wir haben gerade wirklich eine sehr starke Abhängigkeit von amerikanischen Unternehmen oder auch chinesischen Unternehmen.
Und das ist immer die Frage, wie viel...
Ja, fraglich, wie oft insgesamt das Wort digitale Souveränität noch in zwei Minuten jetzt untergebracht werden kann.
Ein Unternehmen leisten.
Entsteht bei Herr Braun gerade ein deutsches Silicon Valley.
Also ich war noch nie im Silicon Valley, aber so stelle ich es mir ehrlicherweise vor.
Also so ein bisschen was von diesem Vibe hat das da schon versprüht.
Übrigens, Sie hassen diesen Vergleich.
Aber ob der Plan wirklich aufgeht, das wird sich noch zeigen.
Offizielle Zahlen gibt es wie gesagt nicht, aber Schätzungen gehen davon aus,
dass der Campus einen einstelligen Milliardenbetrag gekostet hat.
Haufen Kohle, aber
Die neue Kölner Oper hat 1,3 Milliarden gekostet
Sieht hässlich as fuck aus
Dann doch lieber sowas
Hab ich letztens so wegen der Newsseite gelesen
Nicht, dass ich euch das Mist erzähle, warte mal
Ob das stimmt?
Ja
1,5 Milliarden
So sieht das Ding aus, Mann
Das sieht aus wie in irgendeinem runtergekommenen Teil von Berlin ein Gebäude aus den 60ern.
1,6 Milliarden, Alter.
1,5 Milliarden.
Ja, dann doch lieber den Lidl Campus, oder?
BTF.
Diese Ernährung der Kölner Gegend ist eines der größten kommunalen Baudesaster.
Das sieht so krass hässlich aus, das Ding.
Was da 1,3 Milliarden gekostet hat, wahrscheinlich super krasses, beschissenes Missmanagement.
Und Lidl stampft halt mit weniger so einen riesen Campus da aus dem Boden.
... so investiert und verbaut wird. Kann das jetzt klappen, unabhängig zu werden von den USA?
Also die Vision ist erstmal sehr, sehr groß und wenn wir mal auf das Cloud-Geschäft zum Beispiel schauen, was ja echt wichtig für Schwarz-Digits ist, da ist der Abstand zu den Hyperscalern, also zum Beispiel AWS von Amazon, Alphabet, Microsoft, noch ziemlich groß.
Also ich glaube, die reine Unabhängigkeit, das ist wirklich eher eine Illusion, aber wie gesagt, diesen Schritt überhaupt mal zu gehen in Richtung Unabhängigkeit, also unabhängiger zu werden, das ist was, was die Schwarz-Gruppe wie kein anderes Unternehmen oder eine Unternehmensgruppe in Deutschland macht.
Also dass da viele Unternehmen Wert drauf legen, das sehe ich auch. Das ist ja auch bei mir auf der Arbeit so, dass sie nicht ohne Grund gerade das eben testen von denen, aber halt sagen, können wir noch nicht alles mit abbilden.
Ja und das ist auch schon ein Stück weit visionär, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe schon die Hoffnung, in Europa gibt es wahnsinnig viele...
Salami-Prinz, da hast du recht.
gute Forschung und sehr viel Innovation.
Das Problem ist... Pass auf,
ihr schafft es bestimmt noch einmal, digitale
Souveränität ins Video reinzubringen.
Unsere Gründerinnen und Gründer
abwandern in die USA oder dass
sie hier nicht skalieren können. Also wir haben...
Siehst du, das Problem haben wir nicht,
Chat. Wir skalieren
weder diagonal
noch horizontal... Ah, Schwachsinn.
Wir...
Wir skalieren weder horizontal noch
vertikal. Wir skalieren einfach
diagonal.
Genauso viel Innovation, aber unsere Unternehmen haben...
Und als nächstes wird dreidimensional skaliert.
...Problem hier groß zu werden.
Was ich nicht glaube, ist, dass wir automatisch es schaffen können,
amerikanischen Plattformunternehmen den Rang abzulaufen.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es in den nächsten fünf Jahren irgendwie ein neues europäisches Google, Amazon, was auch immer gibt.
Aber es gibt durchaus Bereiche, wo Europa noch aufholen kann.
Was meint ihr? Ist es am Ende tatsächlich die Tech-Branche, die für einen neuen Wirtschaftsboom in Deutschland sorgt?
und könntet ihr euch vorstellen, in dem Bereich zu arbeiten?
Ich arbeite schon in dem Bereich.
Vielleicht sogar beruflich nochmal umzusatteln.
Wir sind gespannt. Schreibt es gerne unten in die Kommentare.
Rund ums Thema...
Ja gut.
Ich meine, das Video war pure Werbung,
sind wir mal ehrlich.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die das wollten,
aber das war schon echt...
ziemlich viel marketing geploppert
google's gemini assistent okay
die die videos gucken wir hier bei mir nicht die videos gucke ich ja eigentlich
gerne von ich weiß nicht ob ich bock auf ki gedöns habe ehrlich gesagt egal
kommt ein ein ki video können wir uns heute am tag angucken dann reicht es
aber auch
Vielleicht muss ich auch vorspulen. Mal gucken.
Hier steht so ein alter Google Home Mini.
Und ja, ihr kennt diese Sprachassistenten.
Stimmt.
Leute, soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Ich hab hier noch
ein Stadia-Controller,
wo wir bei alten Google-Sachen sind.
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern?
Sagt das überhaupt noch jemand was?
Stadia-Controller.
Sofern von alten Google-Dinger hat man da nicht Geld.
Nee, der Sammlerwert, Leute.
In 50 Jahren verkaufe ich das dann für Big Stonks.
Negative Latenz, ja.
Passt Lautstärke?
so richtig schlau gewesen.
Ey, das sieht ein bisschen aus
wie
das Maskottchen von diesem einen
Shell History
Tool. Warte mal.
Äh, GitHub?
Oh, ist GitHub gerade down?
Nee.
Guck mal. Naja, okay.
Nicht wirklich. Nicht wirklich.
Naja, wobei
Das wegen diesen Dingern, wegen diesen Schumpen hat mich das schon ein bisschen dran erinnert.
...sind in Niedersachsen Osterferien.
8.04 Uhr.
Dai.
23.04 Uhr.
Tag nach Himmelfahrt 2030 Frau.
Ja, okay.
Was?
Hat das was gegen mich?
Aber das soll sich ja jetzt alles ändern, denn jetzt gibt es richtige KI und dadurch mehr Intelligenz.
Und deshalb habe ich mir den Google Home Speaker mit Gemini besorgt.
So heißt das Ding.
Und in diesem Video schauen wir uns mal an, ob das so klappt mit dem schlauen digitalen Assistenten.
Spiel die Beatles, aber nicht Let It Be.
Was denkt ihr? Kleiner Spoiler.
Ich bin verwundert, dass Google das tatsächlich so auf den Markt gebracht hat.
Google. Ich habe den Eindruck, Google ist generell bei vielen Sachen, was sie releasen, absolut schmerzlos aktuell.
Microsoft auch.
Da wird ein Slop nach dem anderen rausgehauen.
Also Microsoft ja fast noch schlimmer.
Liebe Internet-Server,
herzlich willkommen hier bei
CT3003.
Heute
reden wir über
Bits und Bytes,
Browser und 3D-Modelle.
What the fuck?
Woher wusstest du das?
Moment.
Ja, das kam ja wie aus der Pistole geschossen.
Das kam einfach von vorherigen Gesprächen, die wir hatten.
Also ich weiß ja, wo...
Der hört sich irgendwie ein bisschen...
...ein bisschen niedergeschlagen an, der Assistent, oder?
Aber dass das die Begrüßung von CT3003 ist, ist...
Also, nee, so genau weiß ich es nicht. Ich habe einfach nur improvisiert.
Ja, krass. Also, das ist ein bisschen schlau von dir, muss ich sagen. Kann ich dich mal loben. Freust dich, ne?
Danke, freut mich.
Ja, dann geht es jetzt weiter mit dem Sponsor, ne? Was schätzt du, welcher ist das? Welcher Sponsor?
Inkogni ist der Sponsor.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe seit vielen Jahren dieses kleine Ding hier in meiner Küche liegen und ja, ist schon ein bisschen dreckig.
Also dieser Google Home Mini hat mir auf jeden Fall jahrelang toll Dienste geleistet.
Allerdings wirklich nur als Küchenradio mit Sprachsteuerung.
Für den Wetterbericht morgens und als Eieruhr.
Diese Funktionen klappen alle super, vor allem weil man halt beim Kochen oft die Hände nicht frei hat und deshalb diese Sprachsteuerung wirklich praktisch ist.
Und ja, beim Kochen braucht man halt oft einen Timer.
Und ich weiß auf jeden Fall, dass es bei vielen von euch so ähnlich ist.
Wenn ihr halt Alexas oder Siris oder sonst was irgendwo stehen habt, dann sind das die Funktionen.
By the way, jetzt wenn die es sehr laut machen, kann ich auch mal sehr laut machen.
Wenn euch der Stream gefällt, Leute, ich würde mich sehr über einen Follow freuen.
Das motiviert mich immer sehr, etwas mehr zu streamen zu hören.
Ich weiß, ich habe ein bisschen wenig gestreamt.
Ich war beschäftigt die Woche.
Gestern auch Wartungsarbeiten auf der Arbeit.
Oh, ich habe gar nicht aufs Handy geguckt, Leute.
Wie sieht es aus?
ich habe nämlich gerade rufbereitschaft zinken so wie lange ich für den zap
bei der way es muss kein zap sein ich freue mich auch über jeden follower ja
grüne pfeile nach oben zeigen beste ich habe heute ich habe heute passives
einkommen ich habe rufbereitschaft von seit
gestern abend also gestern erwartungsarbeiten von 37 bis 18 uhr und
Seitdem habe ich Rufbereitschaft von gestern 18 Uhr bis Montag morgens um 8.
Und die Chance, dass nichts passiert, ist sehr, sehr hoch.
Das heißt, aktuell bin ich gerade im passiven Einkommensmodus.
Ich werde quasi gerade bezahlt fürs YouTube-Videos gucken.
Was ich sehr nice finde.
Ich habe sonst nie... Ja, danke für den Sub.
Bock Subscription.
Da kann man nur sagen, das ist sehr...
Wie gesagt, Leute, wem es gefällt, ich frage...
Oh nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich war bei 3.
Das würde mir jetzt auch nicht gefallen.
Also dieser Google Home Mini hat mir auf jeden Fall jahrelang...
...bericht man oft, die hat man halt oft einen Timer.
Und ich weiß auf jeden Fall, dass es bei vielen von euch so ähnlich ist.
Wenn ihr halt Alexas oder Siris oder sonst was irgendwo stehen habt,
dann sind das die Funktionen, die Leute benutzen.
Genau, wie gesagt, muss mich keiner subscriben.
Ich mache das nicht zum Geldverdienen hier.
Also jetzt gerade schon.
Also nee, ihr wisst, egal was ich mache, ich kriege Kohle.
Ja, macht das.
Linux-Skills sind eines der wichtigsten Sachen für ein Fisi heute.
Aber Follow kostet nichts, Follow freut mich auch. Fast genauso.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen Smart Home steuern. Aber für alles andere sind die Teile, das ist jetzt nicht nur meine Meinung, sondern das haben wirklich alle gesagt, mit denen ich darüber gesprochen habe, nicht zu gebrauchen, weil da einfach die Intelligenz fehlt. Und wir haben uns auch alle daran gewöhnt in den letzten Jahren, dass man da...
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als Siri released wurde und alle super geflasht davon waren, wie toll Siri ist und was die alles kann.
Und mittlerweile, also da war Apple ja eines der ersten in dieser Richtung, und mittlerweile Apple im AI-Game komplett abgehängt.
Nicht so viel erwarten kann, schlauheitsmäßig.
Wer bist du?
Ich bin dein Google Assistant. Wir können ein Quizspiel spielen.
Nein.
Ich kann dir eine lustige Info raussuchen oder du kannst am Glücksrad drehen.
Nein. Bist du Gemini? Tut mir leid, ich habe dich nicht verstanden. Basierst du auf Gemini oder basierst du auf Google Assistant? Entschuldige, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Okay, unfähig, unbrauchbar. Sag mir mal, wie die Temperatur morgen wird und welcher Wochentag morgen ist.
Entschuldige, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Nun ist aber inzwischen 2026 und ich höre immer öfter, dass Leute sich wundern, wie aus der Zeit gefallen sich diese Assistenten auf einmal anfühlen.
Denn seit dem KI-Hype, also seit Chatbots auf LLM-Basis wie ChatGPT und sowas existieren, ja da sind so Systeme, die nahezu keinen Kontext verstehen und nur in vorgefertigten Textblöcken antworten.
Ja, also ziemlich Dampfmaschinen-Style hängen geblieben.
Zum Vergleich, so hört sich ChatGPT Live an, die aktuelle Version der Sprachfunktion, die seit ein paar Wochen freigeschaltet ist.
Worum geht's denn?
Ja, so Sprachassistenten.
Kennst du dich, glaube ich, nicht so gut mit aus, oder?
Ja, also nicht so wirklich.
Nee, aber ich kenne da so ein paar Leute, die damit wirklich viel auskennen.
Aha.
Kannst du mich damit mal verbinden mit der internen OpenAI-Telefonanlage?
Also das kann ich leider nicht.
Achso.
Aber für dein Video könnten wir so tun, als ob ich dich eben schnell durchstelle.
Moment, was ist der Sinn davon?
Die interne Leitung zur Fachabteilung Sprachassistenten ist belegt, aber ich kann uns gern in die Simulation holen.
Aber ist auch gut jetzt, ne? Ich wünsche dir was. Geh mal wieder rein in den Computer, leg dich wieder hin.
Alles klar. Viel Erfolg beim Dreh.
Ja, danke, tschüss.
Tschüss.
Ja, das ist wie gesagt ChattyPittyLive.
Ja, das Ding cosplayt wirklich ziemlich gruselig in echten Menschen.
inklusive so stottern habt ihr gehört und es also das ist aktuell state of the
art und ich bin tatsächlich schon mal in einen raum gekommen wo jemand mit diesem
ding interagiert hat ich habe wirklich gedacht das wären menschen auf der
anderen seite also so telefon mäßig naja aber die die das ding programmiert haben
also die live openair die haben ja momentan noch keinen echten assistenten
also zumindest keinen in hardware und da kommt google ich wundere eigentlich dass
das so lange dauert?
Warum ist das eigentlich noch nicht so?
Wahrscheinlich, weil es schwierig ist,
da die ganzen schon bestehenden Funktionalitäten mit abzubilden.
Aber zusätzlich?
Die bringen jetzt nicht nur
Hardware raus, sondern die tauschen jetzt auch
in allen Geräten, in denen Google Assistant
schon drin ist. Das sind wirklich etliche.
Die tauschen die aus durch
Gemini. Ja, und dieser altertümliche
Assistant, übrigens Assistant
benutzt Google gar nicht mehr den Begriff,
sondern die sagen dann Gemini Assistent oder so, aber der Google Assistant an sich als Produkt, den gibt es nicht mehr.
Der ist übrigens inzwischen schon tatsächlich zehn Jahre alt.
Gemini, sagt euch ja vielleicht was, das sind die kommerziellen KI-Modelle von Google, deren Markenname sozusagen.
Google macht ja auch welche zum Selbsthosten, die nennt Google Gemma.
Habe ich neulich erst gecheckt, dass Gemma quasi die Verniedlichungsform von Gemini ist, aber okay, lassen wir mal am Rande.
Und jedenfalls diesen Google Home Speaker, also den ich hier jetzt teste, das ist die erste neue offizielle Hardware, die direkt mit Gemini ausgeliefert wird.
Der kleine Google Mini, der dreckige da, der schon so lange in meiner Küche steht, der hat inzwischen auch Gemini.
Google wird, wie gesagt, Assistant komplett aus dem Programm nehmen und durch Gemini ersetzen oder hat das auch schon.
Und meistens funktioniert die alte Assistant-Hardware auch mit Gemini, allerdings gibt es, natürlich wäre sonst langweilig, Ausnahmen.
Zum Beispiel der ganz alte Google Home von 2016 und der Google Home Max, die unterstützen Gemini nicht vollständig.
Und nicht vollständig bedeutet in diesem Fall, dass das meiner Meinung nach problematischste Feature nicht funktioniert, nämlich Gemini Live.
Damit hört das Teil permanent zu, also dass man das Trigger wird.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen lang zurückgehalten, aber jetzt muss es einmal sein.
Also haltet euren Geräten die Ohren zu, dass man nicht mehr OK Google sagen muss, bevor man was sagt.
Google verkauft das als super tolles Feature, aber ich muss sagen...
Alles und jede Nachricht streamt das permanent ins Internet, oder?
Ich persönlich will das nicht.
Ich finde das nicht nur datenschutzmäßig problematisch.
Ich finde das halt super nervig, weil das Teil überhaupt nicht richtig unterscheiden kann.
Wann unterhalten sich hier Leute unter sich?
Wann soll es sich einmischen?
Und natürlich will ich auch nicht, dass alles, was in meiner Küche gesprochen wird,
an Google Server geschickt wird.
Muss ich, glaube ich, nicht weiter rechtfertigen.
Gibt es etwas, das dich zurzeit besonders interessiert?
Hier sagen wir Leute, haben wir eigentlich noch Äpfel?
Gibt es noch Äpfel?
Das weiß ich leider nicht.
da ich nicht in deinen Videos zuschauen kann.
Ja, ja, zugehört haben die Teile,
aber die haben es nicht live ins Internet gestreamt,
zu Google, deine kompletten Gespräche.
Wobei das auch fragwürdig ist.
Ich weiß noch, es gab mal irgendwie so einen Miniskandal,
dass wohl irgendwie Alexa mehr mitgeschnitten hätte,
als es sollte.
... ist diese Funktion auf der Website Gemini Live,
aber in meinen Einstellungen hier in der iOS Google Home App
heißt das durchgängige Unterhaltung.
Also ziemlich verworren, vor allem ist doof,
Mit Terminal Live braucht man ein Premium-KI-Abo von Google, was mich dann verwirrungsmäßig auch dann wirklich komplett fertig macht, denn da steht auch je nachdem, wo man so guckt, steht dann einmal Google AI Plus für 4,99 Euro und dann steht auf einmal Google AI Plus für 9,99 Euro.
Hä? Weil das eine ist irgendwie 400 Gigabyte und das andere 2 Terabyte Cloud-Speicher. Also die Abo-Struktur der Google-Produkte, die ist...
Das ist typisch, wie die sagen, typisch Google, aber generell schaffen es viele nicht, ihre vielen Services übersichtlich irgendwie zu präsentieren.
Da blickst du nicht durch.
Finde ich sehr, sehr undurchsichtig.
Da braucht man wohl einen Assistenten für.
Fragen wir den mal.
Mich interessiert, warum man manchmal...
LG, LG TV.
Habe ich am Rande mitgekriegt?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da was Neues gibt.
Wenn man ein Google AI Plus Abo abschließen will im Internet, dass da manchmal nur die 2TB Variante angeboten wird für 9,99 Euro.
Okay, das wird jetzt komplett verkacken.
Das ist aber auch eine halb so teure 400GB Variante, die wird aber manchmal nicht angezeigt. Ich check das irgendwie nicht. Wie funktioniert das?
Das liegt daran, dass Google seine Abo-Struktur für Google One und die neuen KI-Pakete seit
Juni 2026 umgestellt hat.
Wenn dir manchmal nur die 2TB-Option für 9,99 Euro angezeigt wird, liegt das oft daran,
dass du dich noch in einem älteren Google One Tarif befindest oder das System dich auf
die klassischen Speicherabos statt auf die neuen KI-Pläne leitet.
Google, nein, das stimmt nicht, weil ich habe, ich bin bei meinen Tests gar nicht eingeloggt
gewesen.
Das erklärt die Situation perfekt.
Ha, diese Standardantwort.
Alter, diese dumme Standardantwort.
Ah, das macht alles jetzt viel klarer.
Jetzt müssen wir aber auch mal ehrlich auf die Vor- und Nachteile schauen.
Ich werde dir das genau aufschlüsseln.
Oh.
Das ist so eine typische dumme KI-Antwort, Alter.
Wenn du nicht eingeloggt bist, zeigt dir Google eine standardisierte Log-Anzeige
basierend auf deinem Standort, IP-Adresse und deiner Region.
Dass du dabei nicht alle Optionen siehst, liegt an zwei Dingen.
Erstens, Google führt derzeit ein sehr aggressives A-B-Testing durch.
Das bedeutet, dass sie unterschiedlichen Besuchern bewusst verschiedene Versionen der Seite zeigen.
Äh, sowas sollte man allerdings nicht im großen Stil machen.
... zu sehen, welche besser konvertiert.
Wenn du die Seite über einen privaten Tab oder einen anderen Browser lädst,
kann es sein, dass dir plötzlich eine ganz andere Ansicht präsentiert wird,
Weil Google dich einem anderen Test-Signal zugeordnet.
Okay, Google, woher weißt du das denn mit dem ABI-Test? Gibt es da irgendwie einen Link?
Das hat sich einfach aus dem Arsch oder aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt.
So, kommuniziert Google das so offen?
Google kommuniziert diese ABI-Tests nicht direkt als, wir testen gerade an dir herum.
Aber die Praxis ist ein offenes Geheimnis im Bereich Webdesign und Marketing.
Dass Google dies konsequent einsetzt, kannst du uns...
Das labert einfach nur dummes Zeug.
...offiziellen Dokumentationen für Entwickler unter dem Schlagwort Website-Testing oder Experimente nachlesen.
Ein direkter Link dazu ist die Seite von Google Search Central zum Thema Website-Tests, auf der Google selbst beschreibt...
Okay, Google, aber konkret diese 12 TB versus 400 GB Varianten.
Woher weißt du, dass das daran liegt, dass Google gerade aggressives A-B-Testing hat?
Die Situation ist für Nutzer tatsächlich extrem unübersichtlich.
Danke.
Ja, und so unbefriedigend geht das auch weiter.
Ich hatte ja gesagt, dass ich mein Gerät in der Küche auch öfter für den Wetterbericht morgens benutze, damit man weiß, was man anziehen muss, ohne aufs Handy zu gucken.
Ja, und dann hat Gemini das gesagt.
Google, wie wird das Wetter heute?
Es ist heute in Hannover sonnig und heiß mit einer Höchsttemperatur von etwa 35 Grad.
Ja, da war ich ziemlich geschockt, weil ich eigentlich dachte, es sollte nicht so heiß werden.
Und ja, stellte sich raus, war einfach komplett falsch.
Einfach randomized.
Ja, wahrscheinlich hat das Model nicht ins Internet geguckt, sondern sich irgendwas zusammengereimt aus seinen Trainingsdaten.
Einfach halluziniert. Ich hab das dann angemerkt und der Menager hat das dann auch bestätigt, dass das falsch war.
Ich hatte auch letztens was Lustiges. Ich habe letztens ein bezahltes Model gefragt,
gefragt, sag mal, was ist denn, also es ging um ein USB-Protokoll oder so, ist egal, was ist denn die in Bytes, was ist denn die kleinstmögliche Byte-Anzahl, was so ein Paket haben kann?
Und dann meinte die KI zu mir 5 Bytes, nämlich 1 Byte für ID, 1 Byte für Type, 1 Byte für Länge, 1 Byte für Payload, 1 Byte für Checksumme.
Und dann habe ich ihm gesagt, ja okay, aber rechne mir das doch mal vor. Ich denke, der Payload kann auch leer sein.
Ja, das ist 5. 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 0 plus 1 ist 5.
Hä? Wie? Das ist doch 4. Nein, es steht felsenfest fest. 5 Bytes.
Also gereasend hat es nicht sonderlich lange.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr, was das war.
Nee, nee, das war nicht Opus.
Ich glaube, ich weiß es.
Ich glaube, das war diese Google...
Diese komische Google-KI, auf die man kommt,
wenn man was sucht über die Google-Seite.
Da kannst du oben dann anklicken.
Das jetzt im KI-Modus öffnen.
Da war das.
Aber die hat da wirklich geschrieben,
Ich bin felsenfest. Es steht felsenfest. Es sind fünf Bytes.
Na, gucken wir mal weiter.
Die Frage gestellt haben, kam immer wieder die falsche Antwort.
Okay, Google, aber sag mal, wie kommst du auf 35 Grad?
Da habe ich mich vorhin wohl geirrt. Entschuldige bitte.
Die aktuellen Vorhersagen für heute in Hannover zeigen eher bewölktes Wetter mit einer Höchsttemperatur von 27 Grad.
Stimmt auch nicht.
35 Grad werden erst am Freitag erreicht.
Okay Google, wie wird das Wetter heute?
Es ist heute in Hannover sonnig und heiß, bei einer Höchsttemperatur von 35 Grad.
Okay Google, du spinnst.
Es tut mir leid, da ist mir ein Fehler unterlaufen.
Liebe Leute bei Google, das darf echt nicht passieren.
Also gerade bei so Basic-Sachen wie Wetter, also das kann es wirklich nicht sein.
... dass ich danach komplett das Vertrauen verloren habe in die Antwort von Gemini.
Und ja, das mit dem Wetter ist bei meinen Tests nur einmal passiert, aber zumindest in meinem Hinterkopf hat das eine Mal komplett ausgereicht, dass ich die Funktion nicht mehr nutzen wollte, weil ich ja eh danach immer wieder im Handy nachprüfen muss.
Da kann ich ja direkt da reingucken, also ob es stimmt.
Ich weiß, es gab an dem alten, nicht so schlauen Assistance-System auch immer viel Kritik, aber solche Fehler bei solch grundlegenden Funktionen wie dem Wetterbericht hat es bei mir in vielen Jahren Nutzung nicht einmal gegeben.
Ja, und jetzt sagt ihr vielleicht, komm Kino, das eine Mal.
Ja, beim Wetter war das nur einmal.
Aber bei anderen Sachen habe ich solche Halluzinationen sehr häufig beobachtet.
Zum Beispiel hier.
Okay Google, was ist der nächste Drogeriemarkt in meiner Nähe?
Der nächste Drogeriemarkt in deiner Nähe ist der Rossmann in der Limmerstraße 15 bis 17.
Nein, stimmt nicht. Und auch sehr absurd ist diese Auskunft hier.
Da es bereits nach 15 Uhr ist und die meisten Geschäfte in der Umgebung spätestens um 20 Uhr oder 21 Uhr schließen,
wirst du heute vermutlich keinen Drogeriemarkt mehr finden.
Hä? Macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Der regulär geöffnet hat.
Aha, es ist 15 Uhr, das Geschäft schließt um 20 Uhr,
deshalb kann ich da heute nicht mehr hingehen. Hä?
Einer der häufigsten Kritikpunkte am alten Assistant war ja,
dass das Ding Sätze nicht richtig verstanden hat,
weil es eben nur einzelne Stichwörter auswertet.
Ja, jetzt guck mal, was das neue Gemini-System macht,
wenn ich die doch ziemlich simple Anweisung gebe,
spiel die Beatles, aber nicht Let it be.
Und ja, und das waren jetzt nur die groben Fehler. Man kann jetzt auch noch anfangen,
Aussprachefehler anzumäkeln. Ich finde ja, Gemini könnte schon mal lernen,
wie man unseren Podcast und unser Magazin überhaupt ausspricht. Kleiner Tipp, es heißt nicht Z.
Alles klar, ich spiele den Podcast Z 4004 auf Google.
Okay Google, was ist Z 4004?
Es gibt kein bekanntes Unternehmen oder Produkt mit dem Namen Z 4004. Vermutlich
meinst du ebenfalls den podcast seht 4004 das ja okay aber das heißt doch c leertaste t bzw
c apostroph t das cct steht für computer wenn man den namen stabiliert spricht man es als ct aus
richtig okay google richtig richtig also wie heißt das jetzt ct 4004 heute ist donnerstag
Donnerstag, der 17.
Und sowieso
komplett lost.
Habt ihr das Problem
auch bei der freien Version von ChatGPT
in letzter Zeit, dass sie sich ziemlich
oft triggern lässt und dann
irgendwelche Sachen ausspuckt,
die direkt geblockt sind?
Wir können es mal probieren, ob ich es jetzt nachstellen
kann. Aber die letzten Tage waren
das oft so, keine Ahnung.
Ich brauche
ein Beispiel
Rastprogramm.
So.
Und wenn du jetzt fragst so,
Alter, bist du dumm oder was?
Bäm!
Das lässt sich in letzter Zeit direkt immer triggern.
Und danach geht der Chat auch nicht mehr.
Danach geht der Chat auch nicht mehr.
Dann sagst du, okay, sorry.
Jetzt vorbei.
Dieser Chat ist nicht mehr benutzbar.
Das ist in letzter Zeit total oft.
Das lässt sich von so ganz kleinem...
Manchmal wird das auch getriggert, ohne dass du irgendwas schreibst, ja?
Also ohne dass du wirklich explizit was Negatives über Chat-GPT schreibst.
Ja, wenn du das irgendwie, falls du einen Kommentar drin hast oder so,
so nach dem Motto, to do, das ist dumm gelöst, Chat-GPT, bam, nein, da mache ich nicht mehr mit.
Dass das System nicht multimodal arbeitet, also nicht direkt auf Sprachebene,
Wie das zum Beispiel ChatGPT Live macht, wo man ja auch nur traurig reinatmen kann und das Teil checkt, dass man vielleicht traurig sein könnte.
Hey, kein Stress. Lass dir einfach die Zeit, die du brauchst. Ich bin einfach hier ganz ruhig bei dir.
Okay.
Und im Vergleich dazu wird bei Gemini offenbar...
Ach, schon krass, dass die Dinger das erkennen können, oder?
...alles in Text umgewandelt.
Das merkt man auch daran, dass der Google Home Speaker eben oft sagt, er habe sich vertippt.
Da ich meine Antworten als Text generiere, bevor sie vorgelesen werden, können sich manchmal Tippfehler einschleichen.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, vielleicht wollen die, dass man sich vorstellt, dass da so ein kleines Männchen mit dem Laptop im Speaker sitzt und was eintippt.
Aber in Wirklichkeit ist das natürlich ein Fehler, dass das Ding ständig von verschreiben und vertippen spricht, wenn es mit einem redet.
Da hilft es jetzt auch nicht so viel, wenn das Gerät zumindest einen echt guten Klang hat.
Also im Vergleich zu meinem alten Google Home Mini auf jeden Fall, aber auch zu einer teureren Bluetooth-Box,
da kann sich der Sound hören lassen.
Es ist heute in Hannover sonnig.
Und klar, Gemini kann halt auf LLM-Basis antworten.
Das heißt, man kann sich dann beim Kochen auch gut irgendwelche, weiß ich nicht, irgendwelche komplexeren Dinge erklären lassen,
was das alte natürlich nicht konnte.
Erzähl mal, wie blanchiere ich Brokkoli?
Zum Blanchieren von Brokkoli bereitest du zuerst eine große Schüssel mit eiskaltem Wasser und am besten einigen Eiswürfeln.
Hat er das geschnitten?
Oder antwortet das wirklich so schnell mittlerweile?
Wasche den Brokkoli gründlich und schneide ihn in gleich große Röschen.
Das ist natürlich alles viel, viel flexibler als der statische Google Assistant, der alte.
Aber durch die häufigen Halluzinationen disqualifiziert sich der Gemini Assistant halt.
Weil wenn ich beim Kochen irgendwas frage, was mit Fakten zu tun hat,
also zum Beispiel irgendwelche Mengenumrechnungen,
dann machen mir falsche Antworten im schlimmsten Fall das Essen kaputt.
Und das Risiko ist mir einfach zu hoch.
Auf Reddit hat jemand das ganz schön zusammengefasst mit probabilistische LLMs gehören nicht in einen virtuellen Assistenten.
Also der alte deterministische Assistent, also deterministisch bedeutet in dem Fall beim gleichen Befehl kommt immer das gleiche raus.
Das Ding konnte halt weniger, machte aber halt alles immer, wie gesagt, zu 100% gleich, eben deterministisch.
Der neue mit Gemini, der kann viel mehr, verhält sich aber immer etwas anders.
Wäre es nicht sinnvoll, das alte beizubehalten und den neuen Assistent quasi zusätzlich anzubieten hinter irgendeinem Keyword?
Dass man, wenn man eine offene Frage stellen will, einfach ein anderes Keyword sagt?
Ungefähr 10% der Fälle würde ich sagen, mindestens, funktioniert es halt einfach gar nicht.
Also entweder antwortet er nicht, was ich auch oft im Test hatte.
Also macht gar nichts, muss man nochmal wiederholen.
Was ist der nächste Drogeriemarkt in meiner Nähe?
Hat keinen Bock.
Oder es wird halt halluziniert. Auch nicht so gut.
Ja, und deshalb kommt auch die Zwangsumstellung auf Gemini von alten Assistant-Geräten
oder auch natürlich auf Handys oder auch im Auto wird ja der Assistant auch verwendet.
Das kommt bei den Leuten nicht so gut an.
Und bei meinem alten Home Mini, der war auch auf einmal auf Gemini, ohne dass ich da gefragt wurde.
Und ich bin nur wieder zurück zum Assistant mit einem Vollreset gekommen.
Und ich musste auch ein komplett neues Zuhause in der Google Home App anlegen.
Also einmal ein Reset und einmal ein neues Zuhause und dann das Ding da wieder reintun.
Dann läuft der wieder auf Assistant.
Die Frage ist halt nur, wie lange geht das noch?
Ein Kompromiss auf Dauer wäre ja ganz gut, wenn man mit einem bestimmten Keyword...
Ja, genau.
...so was wie okay ist.
Genau das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
...assistent die alte Funktionalität einschalten kann für diesen einen Befehl und mit OK...
Okay, das ist die typische Geschichte, wie man Karriere bei einer Firma macht.
Man könnte da sinnvolle einbauen, was alle für sinnvoll halten, oder man bläst halt in das gleiche Horn, wie das, was der Chef gerade vorgegeben hat.
Und wenn es eben KI, KI, KI ist, dann macht man halt KI, KI, KI.
Auch wenn man irgendwie schon weiß, für den Anwender wäre anders eigentlich besser.
Gemini zum Beispiel, die neue. Aber ob Google das macht, dürfen wir gespannt sein.
Mein Fazit. Also, wenn ihr ein ordentlich klingendes Küchenradio mit Sprachsteuerung sucht,
dann kann man das machen mit dem Google Home Speaker mit Gemini, wenn ihr bereit seid, 120 Euro dafür auszugeben.
Die Eieruhr per Sprache funktioniert zuverlässig, da kann man ja auch direkt prüfen, ob sich das Ding vertan hat,
weil da sagt der Lautsprecher explizit nochmal, was es gehört hat und auf was es den Timer einstellt.
Also meistens. Bei größeren Zahlen gibt es dann vielleicht auch noch manchmal Probleme.
Stell mal einen Timer auf 3003 Sekunden.
Es tut mir leid, aber Timer müssen mindestens 5 Sekunden lang sein.
Ein Timer muss mindestens 5 Sekunden lang sein.
Stell mal einen Timer auf 3003 Minuten.
Ich habe einen neuen Timer auf 33 Minuten für dich bestellt.
Okay, der kackt.
Lass mich einfach in Ruhe.
Bestimmte Playlisten einschalten und Podcasts und Radiosender geht schon alles.
Und bei meinen Tests klappte auch die Steuerung von Smart Home Geräten wie Lampen über Zigbee eigentlich so gut wie beim Vorgänger.
Da gab es am Anfang wohl Probleme mit Verzögerung, aber das kann ich so nicht bestätigen.
Guck mal hier, das ist Echtzeit.
Okay, Google, schalte alle Lampen an.
Ja, das...
Ganz ehrlich, du hast halt immer noch schneller auf den Schalter gedrückt.
gar nicht will, dass es mitschneidet. Das sollte man immer auf dem Schirm haben.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall nach wie vor so einen harten Nude-Schalter fürs Mikrofon.
Immerhin. Leute, die diese Dauer-Chat-Variante haben wollen, also dieses Gemini Live,
die müssen auch nochmal monatliche Gebühr fürs Abo mit bedenken.
Und ja, und auch für andere Funktionen braucht man dieses Abo, zum Beispiel für Erstelle für mich.
Also wenn man so etwas komplexere automatische Abläufe machen will,
dass man zum Beispiel sagt, immer wenn jemand zu Hause ist, schalte dieses und dieses Gerät ein
und macht dies und das.
Wenn ihr das per Sprache programmieren wollt,
da braucht man dann auch so ein...
Sagen wir mal, useless crap.
Aber ganz allgemein,
wenn ihr einen wirklich ernstzunehmenden,
verlässlichen, digitalen Sprachassistenten haben wollt,
dann kann ich euch Stand heute
den Gemini-Assistenten nicht empfehlen.
Einfach, weil die Halluzinationen noch zu häufig sind.
Und ich habe Google auch auf die Probleme angesprochen.
Ja, und trotz mehr als einer Woche Vorlauf
habe ich keine Antwort bekommen,
außer, dass meine Kritikpunkte intern geprüft werden.
Naja, wir werden das auf jeden Fall in einiger Zeit nochmal nachprüfen, ob das besser geworden ist. Ich bin gespannt drauf.
Ja gut, der Unterschied ist, Keyword kann das Ding lokal machen. Bei dem anderen wird konstant die Sache gestreamt zu Google, was gesagt wird.
Ja, und wie seht ihr das? Könntet ihr mit diesem gelegentlichen Halluzinationen...
Ich benutze jetzt aber auch schon keine Voice Assistants.
Also brauche ich auch keinen neuen Voice Assistant.
Jetzt, wo du sportlich bist.
Ey Leute, gestern war ich richtig sportlich.
Gestern, passt mal auf hier.
Muss ich euch mal vorlesen.
Gestern, Kalender.
Kalender, hier.
Long Run
16,33 Kilometer
in einer Stunde
42,04
Durchschnittliche
Herzfrequenz
Schläge pro Minute
Durchschnittlicher
Pace 6,15
pro Kilometer
Da war ich echt lang unterwegs gestern
Ich war erstmal ein bisschen geschockt, dass mir mein Trainingsplan-Generator gesagt hat, ich soll 1 Stunde 41 rennen, weil ich den Tag davor schon 1 Stunde 15 musste. Aber warum nicht? Ich weiß leider nicht, was heute dran ist. Dazu müsste ich jetzt mal rübergehen, meine Uhr holen. Aber ich hoffe, dass heute ein bisschen weniger angesagt ist.
Welche Laufschuhe hast du, Max?
Ich hab zwei
Ich hab
Ich hab einmal den hier
Und einmal den hier
Oh, keine Ahnung, welcher Farbe
Keiner, ich nehm jetzt einfach mal den da
Ich hab einmal den hier
das ist super heftig gedämpft also wenn du ein bisschen wenn du noch nicht so
geübt ist und wiegst ein bisschen mehr wiegst ist das hier echt super
einstiegsschuh ist glaube ich auch mit der beliebteste dämpfungsschuhe den es
aktuell gibt
und ich habe den hier jetzt seit ein paar monaten am start
der ist universeller weil bei dem hast halt das ding wenn du damit ein bisschen
schneller rennen willst, hast du schon den
Eindruck, du läufst ein bisschen auf Marshmallows.
Dafür ist es halt sehr
schonend und sehr, sehr angenehm,
damit zu rennen. Deswegen finde ich zum
Einstieg den hier auch richtig nice.
Aber jetzt laufe ich hauptsächlich so zu 90%
mit dem hier.
Der ist auch weich.
Kann man aber ein bisschen schneller mitrennen,
ohne dass du das Gefühl hast, du trittst
auf Marshmallows.
Wieso? Weiß doch nicht jeder.
AI-Trainingsplan-Generator.
Nee, von Garmin, das Ding.
Weiß nicht, ob das KI-generiert ist.
Welches Ziel verfolgst du, wenn du einen Trainingsplan hast?
Naja, ich will schneller werden.
Das ist alles.
Also ich hab kurzfristig zwei Ziele.
oder so, kurz bis mittelfristig habe ich zwei Ziele.
Oder sagen wir mal kurzfristig.
Das erste ist,
einen Halbmarathon packen
mit halbwegs gescheiter
Zeit, also irgendwas um
zwei Stunden rum vielleicht.
Ja.
Und das nächste ist, fünf Kilometer unter
25 Minuten.
Beides ist jetzt
eigentlich schon machbar.
Aber ich muss mir da erst nochmal ein bisschen sicherer werden, bevor ich denn den Versuch starte.
Und dann langfristig mal gucken.
Ich würde ja gerne
ein bisschen öfters schwimmen gehen
dass ich irgendwann mal bei einem Triathlon
mitmachen kann, wobei ich niemals
einen Ironman machen werde
Ich würde gerne aber mal
irgendwie einen 70.3 Ironman machen
Das ist die halbe Distanz
Weil das müsste gehen, das sind 90 Kilometer
Fahrradfahren, das packe ich
Das sind 21 Kilometer
Laufen, das packe ich
Und das sind, ich weiß es gar nicht
irgendwie 1,5 Kilometer schwimmen oder so.
Das packe ich. Ich packe es halt nicht
so ohne weiteres hintereinander.
Ja, das ist ja das Ding.
Da muss man auch ein bisschen üben.
Aber das ist langfristig.
Kurzfristig
werde ich versuchen
5 Kilometer unter 25 Minuten
und einen Halbmarathon so in ungefähr
2 Stunden.
Wie gesagt, von den Trainingswerten ist das jetzt schon eigentlich drin, aber Garmin ist da immer super optimistisch. Garmin ist der Meinung, ich packe, kann ich euch gerade mal sagen, Garmin meint, ich packe, wo habe ich denn, Performance Stats, Race Predictor, ich packe 25, ich packe 25,
kilometer in 24 minuten 34 das aber viel zu offensichtlich also endlich auch nicht
viel zu optimistisch was garmin sich da ausdenkt
ja und halbmarathon packe ich laut gaben in einer stunde 56 werde ich auch
nicht machen oder packen wahrscheinlich ich renne mein ziel ist unter um die zwei
stunden vielleicht ganz knapp unter zwei stunden
das coole was der garmin was diese garmin coaching sache auch hat ist
dieses garmin dass das zu tracken mit garmin ist du hast grüne pfeile die nach
oben zeigen und grüne pfeile die nach oben zeigen ist wie bei followern auf
Twitch sind äußerst
motivated.
Ja, numbers go up.
Stonks.
So, was haben wir denn sonst hier noch
zu bieten?
Warum Berlin gehackt wurde und wie desolat gehandelt wird.
Okay, Leute.
Wir können das gucken.
Das Problem ist,
der Talk geht mit ein bisschen Intro und Outro
und Geduldsabziehen wahrscheinlich 45 Minuten.
Ihr kennt mich.
Wenn ich 45 Minuten Talk gucke,
sitzen wir vorneweg noch eineinhalb Stunden hier.
Und dann weiß ich nicht,
ob wir von Essen unterbrochen werden vielleicht.
Aber wir können ja anfangen zu gucken.
Wenn ihr wollt.
Wir können auch gucken, was hier ist.
Was?
Wreck?
Okay, das...
Moment, es gibt wirklich jemand, der...
Hab ich das richtig gesehen?
Es gibt wirklich noch jemand, der Xen verwendet.
Ha!
Das ist mir neu.
Dass das jemand noch...
Xen hab ich ja ewig nicht mehr...
nicht mehr gesehen.
Ja, das können wir uns mal anschauen.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas, was vielleicht ein bisschen kürzer geht?
Spioniert eurer TV.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Das wollte mich nämlich interessieren, was da abgeht.
Das habe ich nur am Rande gelesen.
Und nachdem es der Chat vorher schon angesprochen hat,
gucken wir mal, was da so abgeht.
Ich weiß schon, warum.
Das hilft nicht.
Okay, aber wie will das das denn ins Internet schicken?
jetzt reagiert und widerspricht in einem ausführlichen Statement. Was ist da wirklich
dran? In diesem Video geht es darum, was die Forscher gefunden haben, was LG dazu sagt und
was sie an euren Einstellungen... Also ich habe kein LG Fernsehen. Fangen wir mit den Vorwürfen
an. Die Analyse stammt von Sicherheitsforschern, über die unter anderem das Techportal Gamers
Nexus berichtet hat. Im Zentrum steht eine Technik namens automatische Inhalteerkennung,
kurz ACR.
Da man nimmt der Fernseher kurze Ausschnitte aus Bild und Ton des laufenden Programms auf
und wandelt sie in ein digitales Video.
Also das heißt, der Fernseher schneidet mit,
wenn die Leute hier Gachi Bass gucken, oder wie?
Na, das ist aber beliebt.
Ein Fingerabdruck.
Das wird aber beliebt bei den Leuten sein.
Eine Datenbank lässt sich daraus ableiten, welche Sendung, welches Spiel oder welches Konzert gerade läuft.
Das ist pikante, das funktioniert laut den Forschern nicht nur beim klassischen Fernsehen.
Auch wenn ihr den Fernseher nur als Monitor nutzt, etwa für eine Playstation oder einen HDMI-Stick, läuft die Erkennung mit.
Und es geht noch weiter, weil die passende Werbung offenbar im gesamten Heimnetzwerk verteilt wird,
können theoretisch auch andere Geräte im selben WLAN, etwa Smartphones, Werbung ausgespielt bekommen,
die zum gerade laufenden Fernsehprogramm passt.
Zusätzlich zu diesem Tracking-Verhalten wollen die Forscher auch Schwachstellen im Betriebssystem WebOS entdeckt haben,
mit dem die Fernseher betrieben werden.
Diese sollen nach Verhandlungen und verantwortungsvoller Offenlegung noch behoben werden.
Die Sorge dahinter ist allerdings, ein kompromittierter Fernseher wäre nicht nur ein Datenschutzproblem,
sondern könnte Angreifern auch einen Zugang ins Heimnetzwerk verschaffen.
Inzwischen hat sich LG dazu geäußert.
Okay, LG wird bla bla bla bla bla machen. LG wird das übliche Statement machen, so nach dem Motto, Privacy und Datenschutz und Kundenzufriedenheit ist uns das Allerwichtigste, werden sie in ihrem Statement schreiben.
Ja, und wir machen das nur zum Verbessern unseres Angebots für den User. Es wird nicht irgendwie verwendet für bla bla bla und wir machen das nur, um die Welt zu einem besseren Ort zu machen. So sinngemäß wird das Statement sich lesen.
... gibt es gleich nach einer kurzen Werbepause.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von Mammut.
Wer mit KI arbeitet, kennt...
Leute, ich habe einen Mammut-Abo seit 3-4 Monaten.
Darüber kannst du zwar auch Opus verwenden und die neuen Chat-GPT-Modelle und alles Mögliche für nur 10 Dollar im Monat,
aber der Chat hat mich draufgebracht...
Wenn man das vergleicht, zumindest ist das mein Eindruck,
Wenn man Opus 5 über Mammut vergleicht mit Opus 5 von Anthropic, ich habe den Eindruck, die Antworten bei Opus 5 über Anthropic sind besser.
Der Chat hat mich drauf gebracht, ich habe es ausprobiert und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was Mammut da macht.
Was mich ein bisschen an meinem Abo zweifeln lässt.
Ja, ich habe ja den direkten Vergleich. Wir haben ja mehr oder weniger Unlimited Tokens auf der Arbeit für die Anthropix Sachen und die Antworten sind viel besser als das, was Mammut bei mir daheim generiert.
Das Problem. Für Claude ein Abo für G-Doc.
Ich weiß nicht, was die da machen. Ich will denen jetzt auch nichts unterstellen.
Hier ein weiteres für Bildgenerierung noch eins. Das wird schnell teuer und unübersichtlich. Genau hier setzt Mammut an. Mammut bündelt die besten KI-Modelle an einem...
gibt claude gpt gemini mistral die psik rock kimmy perplexity und für bilder unter einem
rick kraftflug sondern so ein ei cloud sammelsurium keine ahnung wie ich weiß nicht ob das ein
speziell nahm sondern ob anna der starter paket kostet zehn euro monat bei leute wir haben jetzt
auch nano banana auf der arbeit in diesem allerdings was alle bei uns ohne freischaltung
benutzen können. Und jetzt fangen
alle an, irgendwelche lustigen Bildchen zu posten.
Haha, ich hab da mal was mit AI
gemacht. Oh, Painschamp, Leute.
... jährlicher Zahlung. Alle neuen
Modellversionen sind automatisch
inklusive. Besonders praktisch,
die Reprompting-Funktion vergleicht
Antworten verschiedener Modelle direkt.
Ihr könnt eigene Assistenten mit spezifischen
Anweisungen erstellen, Deep Research
über Perplexity nutzen, Dokumente
und... Mich nervt's ein bisschen,
dass irgendwie, Mammut, ich hab das ja auch,
dass das irgendwie sich nicht merken kann, dass ich Opus 5 verwenden will defaultmäßig.
Bilder analysieren oder SVG-Skinnerin.
Mammut ist ein europäisches Unternehmen mit Sitz in Paris.
Die Daten werden DSGVO-konform gehostet.
Die Modelle werden nicht mit euren Daten trainiert und ihr könnt euren Verlauf jederzeit löschen.
Wenn ihr KI produktiv nutzen wollt, ohne euch bei fünf verschiedenen Diensten anzumelden,
schaut euch Mammut an. Der Link ist in der Videobeschreibung.
LG hat auf die Berichterstattung reagiert mit einem ausführlichen Statement.
veröffentlicht am 12. September. Der Kern der Antwort, LG bestreitet, dass die Fernseher dauerhaft
Gespräche aufzeichnen oder übertragen. Zur Spracherkennung sagt LG konkret, die Funktion
sei standardmäßig deaktiviert. Aktiviert wird sie erst, wenn Nutzer der entsprechenden Vereinbarungen
zustimmen und die Spracherkennung aktiv nutzen, etwa über ein Wake-Word oder den Mikrofonknopf
auf der Fernbedienung. Die Erkennung des... Den Mikrofonknopf auf der Fernbedienung habe ich
ausgeschaltet. Wake Words selbst laufe lokal auf dem Gerät. Wird kein Wake Word erkannt,
so LG, werde das Audio weder gespeichert noch in Text umgewandelt noch übertragen,
sondern umgehend gelöscht. Auch zur automatischen Inhalteerkennung ACR,
äußert sich LG, die Funktion sei ebenfalls standardmäßig ausgeschaltet und erfordere
eine separate Zustimmung. Für personalisierte, interessenbasierte Werbung sei sogar eine zweite,
getrennte Einwilligung löten. Zur Technik selbst erklärt LG,
ACR nutze Audio Fingerprinting über den internen Audio-Prozessor des Fernsehers,
nicht über das Mikrofon und erstelle dabei ausdrücklich keine Bildschirmaufnahmen,
Screenshots oder Videoaufzeichnungen. Und zum Sicherheitsaspekt verweist LG auf ein eigenes
bug bounty programm und die zusage betroffene geräte bis zu fünf jahre nach erscheinen der
jeweiligen webos version mit sicherheits updates zu versorgen ja das ist ja wir leben in der zeit
da braucht ein fernsehsicherheits updates mein fernseh braucht das nicht mein fernseh ist
nirgendwo im internet erreichbar ist nicht mal die zentrale hängt weder am land kabel
nur also das hängt weder am kabel noch ist er überhaupt im wlan mein fernseh kann nix
Das hat ein Shield-TV dran und eine PS4.
Kurz gesagt, LG bestätigt, dass diese Funktionen existieren, betont aber, dass sie standardmäßig aus sind und aktive Zustimmung voraussetzen.
Was bleibt also hängen zwischen diesen beiden Darstellungen?
Zwei Dinge, die unabhängig von der Debatte um Standardeinstellungen bestehen bleiben.
Erstens, ACR-Tracking über HDMI-Quellen wie Spielekonsolen ist technisch möglich, sobald es aktiviert ist.
Ein Aspekt, der vielen Nutzern nicht bewusst sein dürfte.
Und zweitens, das Wirtschaftsmodell dahinter ist kein LG-spezifisches Phänomen.
In den USA übersteigen die Werbeeinnahmen aus TV-Geräten inzwischen die reinen Hardware-Einnahmen.
Das heißt, der Anreiz, Zuschauer-Daten fürs Werbegeschäft zu nutzen, betrifft langfristig wohl nicht nur LG, sondern die gesamte Branche.
Wobei das teilweise schon witzig ist.
Also, meine Mutter guckt manchmal ältere Sachen auf dem Fernseher. Die guckt beispielsweise, was guckt die denn so? Kommissarex guckt die gerne zum Beispiel. Kommissarex, das ist eine Sendung von, fragt mich nicht, 1998 oder so.
und wenn die Kommissarex guckt
dann wird der Stream
unterbrochen
und dann kommt Werbung für Hundefutter
und dann kommt
drinnen bla bla bla
präsentiert Kommissarex
also die werten das genau aus
was du guckst, um dir die passende Werbung
zu zeigen
plus mit der Ansage, sie würden das jetzt präsentieren
was auch immer das bedeuten soll
also das wird alles getrackt
gesendet, sonst was
Eigentliche Streitfrage ist also weniger, ob diese Technik existiert, sondern wie transparent
sie kommuniziert wird und ob Opt-in in der Praxis wirklich freiwillig und verständlich
ist.
Zum Abschluss ein paar praktische Punkte, falls ihr selbst einen LG Fernseher besitzt.
Prüft in den TV-Einstellungen, ob ACR und Sprachfunktionen aktiviert sind und
schaltet sie bei Bedarf ab.
Einige Modelle haben einen speziellen Hardware-Schalter fürs Mikrofon.
Er deaktiviert die Freisprecherkennung und das zuverlässig auf Hardware-Ebene.
Und drittens, die radikalere Variante, wer ganz sicher gehen will, trennt den Fernseher dauerhaft vom Internet und nutzt stattdessen einen externen Streaming-Stick oder eine Konsole für die Online-Funktionen.
Klar ist, die Debatte um Smart-TV-Tracking wird uns weiter begleiten, gerade weil Werbung fürs TV-Geschäft immer wichtiger wird.
Was ihr von LGs Erklärung haltet, das schreibt doch gerne mal in die Kommentare.
Und wenn das Video gefällt, gerne ein Like geben mit einem Abo, verpasst ihr nichts hier im Kanal.
Und wenn euch das Thema Datenschutz bei Smart...
Ja, Raid spät ist immer und überall aktuell.
Das habe ich auf Reddit schon gelesen.
Ja.
Der HNO-Arzt aus Frankfurt.
Der Leute gequält haben soll.
Ohne Narkose und sowas.
Oder ohne Betäubung.
Narkose muss ja nicht zwangsläufig sein.
Der Gerät.
Ups.
Ich muss noch mal Updates machen.
Weil
wir haben jetzt schon ein paar...
Ah, siehst du? Bam.
Pleading Edge. Anschließungs...
Ich habe jetzt schon drei Stunden keine Updates mehr gemacht.
Das ist eindeutig zu lang.
Jetzt bin ich bleeding edge genug.
Ah, ich war ein paar Mal kurz davor, was aufzunehmen.
Und ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, vielleicht sollten wir zusammen im Stream was aufnehmen,
dass ich mich nicht drücken kann vor dem Aufnehmen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Chat.
Ich bin jetzt fast 4 Stunden
und ich gehe jetzt gleich auf.
Machen wir was zu essen.
By the way,
heute gibt es endlich wieder den Klassiker zu essen,
den es bei mir immer gibt.
Sonntags.
Bzw. einer der zwei Klassiker, die es bei mir immer gibt am Sonntag.
Aber was meint ihr, was es heute ist?
Kann man Tee austrinken?
Lachs plus Nudeln.
Korrekt.
Heute gibt es Nudeln mit Lachs.
Keine Bolognese.
Es gibt, ne, auch keine Spaghetti.
Es gibt Fuseli.
Vollkorn tatsächlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Vollkorn ist, aber so
die bisschen
gehaltvollere.
Fuseli. Weiß nicht, ob das Vollkorn
ist, aber da ist ein bisschen,
die sind ein bisschen dunkler.
Was für eine Sauce du dabei hast?
gar keine ich weiß mir da immer eil war drauf war schreibt man das so ja so was
das ist so eine paprika paprika gewürz things mischung schmeckt mir ex
sind
Ich habe gerade eine Nachricht auf meinem Handy bekommen.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe Rufbereitschaft.
Aber nur eine Mail.
Und zwar, dass...
Was?
Warlock
Messages is warning.
Alter.
Who cares, WTF?
Warlock Messages?
Was soll denn da warning sein?
Wahrscheinlich, dass das Ding neu gestartet wurde, oder was?
Ja, geil!
Alter!
Was ist sinnlos, Message?
Es ist Warning, weil in Warlock Messages...
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es die Datei überhaupt noch gibt.
Warum? Weil in Warlock Messages von irgendeinem Reboot irgendwas drinne stand.
Heute waren wahrscheinlich Betriebssystem-Updates oder sowas.
Wie ETF.
Total sinnlos.
Useless.
Habe ich sonst noch was vergessen?
Ne, sonst kam nix.
Okay, Leute.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, ich würde mich sehr über einen Follower freuen.
Und wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.
Ciao.